REVIEW ALREADY INDICATED THE
MINUTE MARKERS SO I'M GONNA
BANG THE GAVEL NOW. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW WILL BEGIN A SORRY.
WELCOME TO ORDER. AND GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IF
YOU'RE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR THOSE SENATORS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ME COULD
YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES
NOW AND IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT
STEP WITH YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEM. NOW ALSO. ARE
THERE ANY REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
YES I SEE. A SENATOR MELENDEZ
YES MADAM CHAIR SENATOR MELINDA
IS HERE AND I DO HAVE SUPPORT
STAFF HERE WITH ME- NICKY IS IN
THE OTHER ROOM SAFELY PROTECTED.
THANK YOU BYE DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHERS- MEANING
MEMBERS- WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ALL REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES AND COMPUTERS
WHEN YOU. SPEAK WITH US. THE
SHOPS LUMINATE ACOUSTIC FEED.
AND WHEN YOU WHICH TO BE
WRECKED USED REACHED HAND
FEATURE IN THE- WHEN I
RECOGNIZE WOULD POP UP WINDOW
WILL APPEAR ASK IF YOU'D TO ON
MUTE SELECT THAT ON MUTE BEFORE.
THE I. T. PERSON WILL YOU YOU
WHEN YOU ARE. AND- ONCE I
RECOGNIZE PLEASE BE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THIS. STATE NAME
AND THEN YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW ACCESS
WE'VE OMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. TO CAST BY
BY TELECONFERENCE. D. TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE THAT YOU
CAN USE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN WHEN WE
GET TO THAT POINT FOR YOUR
INFORMATION TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SIX
ONE ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND
FOR INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THAT
SYSTEM WORKS YOU MAY GO TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
THAT FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTOR HEARING IS CLOSE TO
THE MACHINE MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES DUE TO THE USE OF
THESE ONLNE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES SO I ASK FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. SO WOULD
BEFORE WE BEGIN- MISTER
SHOPPING CHAU LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS SKINNER I'M HERE.
SKINNER PRESIDENT. THERE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN PRESIDENT
SINNER CABALLERO CHECK OUT OUR
PRESENT SENATE CORTESE. CENTER
CORTESE PRESENT THIRD DOLLY
THIRD DOLLAR PRESENT SENATOR
RAZA SANTA ROSA PRESENT CENTER
EGGMAN SKINNER EGGMAN PRESENT
CENTER GROVE. SINNER LAYER
CENTER LAYERED. SENATE MCGUIRE.
CENTER MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HERE
MELENDEZ PRESENT SINNER MAN
THURMOND PRESENT SENATOR NEWMAN-
NEWMAN PRESENT. CENTER OCHO
BLOW. CENTER PAN SIR PAN
PRESENT SYNERON THE ROCK
PRESENT CENTER STERN SENIOR
WHITE COUNTY SAN WHITE HOUSE BE
PRESENT. WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. ALL RIGHT- SO WE
WILL BE. HEARING WILL BE
HEARING AND VOTING ON SIX BILLS
AND THEN WE WILL FOLLOW THAT
WITH AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM SB
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH IS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THE BILLS ALL OF THE
BILLS THAT WE ARE. BOTH VOTING
ON TODAY AND HEARING ARE PART
OF A NINE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLAR STATE STIMULUS BUDGET
PACKAGE. AND THE FOCUS OF THEIR
PACKAGES TO PROVIDE DIRECT
RELIEF TO OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND OUR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
AND I WILL NOTE WELL THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT RELATE
TO SUPPORTING SMALL BUSINESS
AND BUSINESS IN GENERAL. THAT
TOTAL FOR SUPPORT BUSINESSES IS
FOUR POINT SEVEN BILLION AND
THAT INCLUDES- SOME FEE WAIVERS
TAX CONFORMITY THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS WHICH WE WILL
GET INTO MUCH DETAIL ABOUT AND
OTHER ITEMS- THIS CALL TWENTY
TWENTY. EMPLOYMENT RATES FOR
HIGH WAGE WORKERS RETURNS TO
THE PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS HOWEVER
ARE LOWER WAGE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED. AND WITH CONTINUED
EITHER UNEMPLOYMENT NEW
UNEMPLOYMENT REDUCED HOURS. THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WILL PROVIDE DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO APPROXIMATELY
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. DESPITE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS MORE THAN 40% OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES REPORT NEEDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND THAT'S
HOW WE ARE RESPONDED WITH THIS
PACKAGE TODAYAND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM FOR FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS. AND IN THAT
FIRST ROUND OF APPLICATIONS
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES APPLIED
SPEAKING OVER FOUR BILLION IN
ASSISTANCE TODAY'S PACKAGE WILL
ALLOW FOR AT LEAST THREE
ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS. IN THE COMING
MONTHS WHICH INCLUDES SMALL
NONPROFITS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER HEARING
ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
AND WE WILL VOTE ON ALL OF THE
BILLS EXCEPT THE INFORMATIONAL
ITEMS AFTER THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND- VICE CHAIR NIELSEN DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
PRESENTATION ON AB EIGHTY FIVE.
FIVE MIKE- SORRY YOUR SON IS
NINE YOUNG. GO AHEAD TRY AGAIN
AS WE EMBARK NOW- MORE FORMALLY
ON OUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS
I'VE GOT A- BLACKS CAUTIOUS
THAT I WOULD ARGUE OUR BUDGET
IS ONLY PRECARIOUSLY BALANCED.
AND WHAT REVENUES THAT THERE
SEEMS TO BE THAT ARE ADDITIONAL
AND WE'RE NOT QUITE ANTICIPATED
WE SHOULD BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT
AND THAT WE SHOULD BE DEVOTING
RESOURCES TO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES AND TO DEBT
RETIREMENT AND NOT FORGET THOSE
OBLIGATIONS BEFORE WE HAD MAJOR
CATEGORIES OF ADDITIONAL LONG
TERM EXPENSES AND SOME OF. THE
ARE ALREADY INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET THAT WILL BE LONG TERM
BUDGET BUILDING EXPENDITURES
AND WE NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU US
SENATOR NIELSEN AND BY BEFORE I
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN AB EIGHTY FIVE WHAT
BY DIDN'T MENTION IS THAT. THE
WHAT WE ARE HEARING TODAY. IT
BUILDS UPON THE ANNOUNCEMENT BY
THE GOVERNOR IN JANUARY FOR
EARLY ACTIONS WHICH I THINK WAS
LOOKED TO BY MANY CALIFORNIANS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES AS AN
INCREDIBLE THAT. IT'S
SUPPORTING THE PUT THE
SITUATION THEY'RE FACING. AND
IN OUR DISCUSSIONSARE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE AND OUR
LEADERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO COME UP WITH A FAR MORE
ROBUST PACKAGE AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO ALL
OF THE STAFF IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND LEADERSHIP. FOR
ASSISTING US IN ACHIEVING THE
PACKAGE THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING
TODAY SO NOW- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN YOU START ON AB
EIGHTY FIVE. YEAH GOOD MORNING
SHARE SKINNER BASTYR NIELSEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
COOLEY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I'M HERE DOING WITH
SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO-
PERCENT ANSWER QUESTIONS ON A
SUITE OF BILLS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AN IMMEDIATE BUDGET
ACTION AS WAS MENTIONED. THAT
WILL PROVIDE CASH RELIEF TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
NEED SUPPORT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE FORM OF
GRANTS HE WAIVERS AND TAX
RELIEF AMONG OTHER SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSAL AS- THE STARTING WITH
EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THAT AMENDS
THE CURRENT BUDGET ACTS- THIS
BILL INCLUDES VARIOUS BUDGET
AMENDMENTS SUCH AS- PROVIDES A
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID
FOR QUALIFYING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
PROVIDES TWENTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. TO RE ENGAGE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE LEFT THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDIES
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC OR TO
ENGAGE. STUDENTS AT RISK OF
CLEANING. THEY ALSO. SIX POINT
ONE MILLION TWO SUPPORT REGION.
ASSISTANCE TO UCCS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN MADE NEWLY L.
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH THROUGH
THE CORONA VIRUS REALLY FELL.
IT PROVIDES ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
SIXTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES TO PROCESS THESE
ADDITIONAL CALFRESH
APPLICATIONS. THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES NINE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE. MILLION DOLLARS TO ISSUE
SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR ONE TIME
GRANT PAYMENTS TO HOUSEHOLDS
ENROLLED IN THE COMPLEX PROGRAM
AND TO RECIPIENTS OF PESTICIDE
SS P. AND CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS ALSO
CALLED CAPPY. IT ALSO ROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE CALVERTS
PROGRAM BY DISREGARDING
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME
FROM ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS
FOR CAL WORKS VERSUS-
APPLICANTS. THIS NEW POLICY
ALIGNS WITH THE CURRENT FEDERAL
EXEMPTION IN PLACE FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL REMAIN IN
EFFECT UNTIL THE FEDERAL
EXEMPTION EXPIRES. IT ALSO
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION TO FOOD BANKS AND AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION FOR
DIAPERS TO FAMILIES IN NEED-
AND PROVIDES TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES-
TO FIND UP TO TWENTY COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. BETTER
EITHER QUARANTINING AND HOME-
OR IN A HOTEL. THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND-
THE B. B. J. OR EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISLI. FIVE LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. SENATOR DORADO. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
REGARDS TO THE- E. I. T. C. I.
T. N. IS THAT IS CORRECT THE.
UNDER ITEM. THE BILL JUNIOR HAS
AN ALLOCATION FOR THE RAMS FOR
THE- BY S. WE WILL BE TALKING
LATER ON ON IN REGARDS TO THE-
I THINK IT'S WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO OKAY. THANK YOU
SIR. AND SENATOR DOLE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- IN THIS AB
FIVE THERE'S THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED. AND I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS THIRTY FIVE MILLION
IT'S THE SAME AMOUNT THAT- WAS-
TALKED ABOUT. EARLIER WITH THE
SPECULATION OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE USING IT FOR- AN ILLEGAL
CONTRACTED SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THERE'S NOT IN RUN
HERE IN THIS BILL TO PUT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND I WANT
TO GUARANTEED IT IS NOT GOING
TO GO TO PAY. LAST YEAR'S TEAM
BIDEN'S- GET OUT THE VOTE WHICH
WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO COUNTIES
AND DID NOT GO TO COUNTIES AND
IT WENT TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE SO THAT I HAVE TO
REASSURANCE WHERE THAT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING
TO GO. THE PART READ NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT THE BILL
DOES INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT DOES
AUTHORIZE THE TRANSFER OF
FUNDS- UNDER UNDER THE
SECRETARY OF STATE- THE
EXPENSES IN REGARDS TO THE
VENDOR OR LEGALLY MADE BUT
THERE WAS NOT THE AUTHORITY
UNDER THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
CONTROLLER SO THIS IS A
TECHNICAL YOU KNOW THAT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION WAS APPROPRIATED
HIGHER ON BUDGET ACTS. OF THIS
IS JUST TECHNICAL YOU KNOW. LET
ME MAKE SURE I AM SO. IN LESS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE MONEY WAS
ALLOCATED GO TO SCHOOLS BUT IN
THIS BUDGET WE'RE ALLOCATING IT
TO GO OUT TO THE SECRETARY
STATE SO THAT YOU ARE YOU I
KNOW YOU'RE AWARE- THERE'S A
LAWSUIT ABOUT THIS AND ABOUT
THE LEGALITY OF. THIS CONTRACT
AND THERE'S BEEN. SOME FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY- EVEN THAT
CONTROLLER. WHO IS NOT BEEN
WILLING TO PAY THIS BILL SO
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME IS THAT.
IT WASN'T RIGHT IN THE YEAR
PRIOR BUT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
IT RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY TAKE THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION AND PAID. AN ILLEGAL
CONTRACT BY CHANGING THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
SO WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE LEGAL BUT
THERE WAS NOT BE A FORTY FOUR
THAT SECRETARY OF STATE HEY-
THERE WASN'T CLEARED FORTY AND
I'LL I'LL- WILL. ASKED MY
COLLEAGUE ANNIE DRIVERS TO
RESPOND WITH ANY DETAILS THANK
YOU. ASSURANCE ARE DROPPED OFF
AND FOR CAR. THE FUNDS GO TO
PAY NOT CONTRACT THE VENDOR.
DID DO THE WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE AND THE INTENT WAS
FOR THIS TO PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT MESSAGE STATEWIDE TO
IMPROVE- VOTER EDUCATION OUR
REGION. DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THE WORK WAS DONE BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE OR ENTERED
INTO THAT CONTRACT ON BEHALF OF
COUNTIES. AND THE INTENT WAS
REALLY JUST AGAIN TO PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT MESSAGE SO THIS
LANGUAGE JUST CLEANS UP- ARE
PROVIDES THE TECHNICAL
AUTHORITY FOR THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO ACTUALLY ISSUE
PAYMENT TO THE VENDOR. I THINK
OF I WAS A CASE OF A IS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS. ACTUALLY I WAS
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO DO IT
I BELIEVE THAT THE SECRETARY
STATE JUST DID IT. AND SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
DAYLIGHT IT OUT THAT. THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THAT. THERE
IS A CONTRACT THAT. OF WITH
VERY. NARROW CONTRACT WITH VERY
LITTLE SCRUTINY AND EVEN THE
CONTROLLER. DIDN'T DIDN'T PAY
THE BILL SO THERE'S SOME
CONTROVERSY OVER HOW THE
CONTRACT WAS LET AND IN THIS
BUDGET. THIS ALLOWS THEM TO GO
PAY THAT CONTRACT EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S A LOT OF A-
CONSTERNATION ABOUT HOW THE
CONTRACT WAS LEFT SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S OUT IN THE
PUBLIC TO THE PUBLIC UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING WHAT
IS HAPPENING IS. THE CONTROLLER
WOULD NOT PAY THE BILL THE
COUNTIES DIDN'T ASK FOR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO DO THIS
CONTRACT THE SECRETARY STATE
DID THE CONTRACT AND NOW A YEAR
LATER WERE COMING BACK. TAKING
TAXPAYERS MONEY- AND USING IT
TO PAY THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON A CONTRACT THAT WAS
LET OUT THAT THERE'S A LOT OF.
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHO RAN THAT CONTRACT AND
HOW IT WAS. TO GET PEOPLE OUT
TO VOTE SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR THAT MEMBERS
KNOW. THAT THIS IS A I DON'T
BELIEVE A- THE RIGHT WAY TO GO
ABOUT IT WE SHOULD IF THE
CONTROLLER AND MANY OF THE
COUNTIES AREN'T ASKING FOR THEN
WE SHOULDN'T BE DOING THIS IS
TAXPAYER MONEY. THAT WENT TO. A
NARAL CONTRACTED IT HELPED ONE
PARTY AND I THINK THAT'S WRONG.
SENATOR THE YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
AM FIRST OF ALL AND LET ME JUST
SAY THAT- HI BELIEVE THAT THE-
RESOURCE THAT ARE PART OF THIS
BY BILL JUNE ARE REALLY AND
RESOURCE TO GET OUT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO BE HERE EXCITED TO BE SAYING
THIS TO MEET SOME REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL NEEDS IN OUR IN OUR
STATE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT HOUSING FOR THE HARVEST
PROGRAM IS- IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT IN MY DISTRICT- I
HAVE SIX OF THE TWENTY COUNTIES
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED TO RECEIVE-
SOME ASSISTANCE TO HELP
FARMWORKERS TO QUARANTINE
DURING THE TIME OF THE CORONA
VIRUS AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS ALSO INCLUDES. THE
OPPORTUNITY IT'S A IT'S A
BRIDE- BUCKET THAT WOULD ALLOW
FARMWORKERS TO BE ABLE TO ALSO
RECEIVE REPLACEMENT WAGES AND I
JUST WANNA- CONFIRM THAT AND
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
PUTTING THAT IS PART OF THE
PROGRAM I UC BERKELEY STUDY
VERY CLEARLY. INDICATED THAT
THAT YOU CAN'T. YOU GET THIS
CALL THIS CALL VIRUS CONTROL IF
YOU HAVE LOW WAGE WARN EARNERS
THAT ARE ASKED TO QUARANTINE
BUT ALSO HAVE TO FEED THEIR
FAMILY AND SO. I'M JUST WHAT
I'M LOOKING. FOR- CLARIFICATION.
YEAH I'M GONNA HAVE TO QUESTION
TO- BY COLLEAGUES ARE YOU ARE
YOU ARE FOR THE DETAIL. GOOD
MORNING SIR DR APARNA FINANCE
YEAH THAT IS CORRECT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL THERE IS- THE DIRECT
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THAT-
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO. THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THAT- HOUSING
FOR THE HARVEST PROGRAM. ALL
RIGHT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS- FIVE CENTER
PAN GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- FIRST OF ALL I. WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT WENT
INTO THE BILLS WE HAVE TODAY
INCLUDING THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR- CERTAINLY- ONE
EXPRESSED THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT AS WE SEE THE- HOPEFULLY
WE'RE SEEING THE LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL WITH- THE
VACCINATION EFFORTS AND SO
FORTH THAT WERE ENGAGED AND-
COVERED BUT- AS WE WERE
APPROACHING THAT WE'RE NOT OUT
OF THE TUNNEL AND WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE- FUNDING
THAT WILL HELP. SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS SO FOR THEIR IN
THIS BUDGET- SAID THAT- SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY IT'S AN
INVESTMENT THAT WILL RETURN TO
US I THINK IN FUTURE YEARS I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME EXTRA
CONCERNS EXPRESSED ABOUT- OUR
FISCAL SITUATION GOING FORWARD-
I WE DID ONE PARTICULARLY-
STRICTLY JUST MENTION AND-
THAT- APPRECIATE THAT WE ALSO
INCLUDED FUNDING TO ADDRESS-
EIGHT AND STATE INCIDENTS
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS- THIS CHAIR
OF THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THIS IS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM- WELL IT'S A LONG
STANDING PROBLEM IT'S GOTTEN
PARTICULARLY WORSE IN THE PAST
YEAR AND MOST RECENTLY WE'VE
SEEN SEVERAL EXAMPLES OF
HORRIFIC ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND
EVEN MURDER AGAINST API- AND-
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THE STATE- ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE THAT-
THERE IS. A SOME FUNDING TO- TO
DO- VERY IMPORTANT RESEARCH AND
STUDIES- SOMETHING THAT WE DID
ASK IN THE LAST BUDGET BUTTON
FORTUNE WAS NOT PART OF THE
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO- TO ENGAGE AND NOW TO
DRESS THAT VERY IMPORTANT-
NEEDS OF THE H. I. COMMITTEE
WHICH REPRESENTS ACTUALLY ONE
IN SX CALIFORNIANS. SO I
REGION I'D VOTE- ALL RIGHTS
RESERVED SUPPORT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR- BUDGET. BILL JUNIOR
I'M THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
MEMBERS FOR A- COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AND AS I IN IN THE
BIG WE WILL DO THE VOTE AFTER
WE HEAR ALL OF THEM AND AFTER
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING BUT I
DID WELL MY OPENING REMARKS
FOCUSED VERY MUCH ON OUR SMALL
BUSINESS SUPPORT IN OUR GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS I DO THINK IT'S
WORTH POINTING OUT THAT SOME
MEMBERS HAVE. THAT THIS BUDGET
BILL PROVIDES AN INCREASE OF
FUNDS TO OUR STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM FOR VERY NEEDED CHILD
CARE IT RESTORES THE FUNDING TO
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
CSU'S YOU SEE AND THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT ALSO
PROVIDES EMERGENCY STUDENT AID
TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
HAVE SEEN A DROP IN ENROLLMENT.
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH
I THINK NONE OF US WANT TO SEE
IN THIS TIME AND- SO PROVIDING
EMERGENCY STUDENT AID MAY HELP
THAT. AND IT ALSO- PROVIDER FOR
US. ASSISTANCE TO OUR FOOD
BANKS AND DIAPER BANKS AND A
SENATOR CAFIERO MENTIONED THE
HOUSING FOR THE HARVEST FOR OUR-
FARMWORKERS SO IT HAS SOME
ADDITIONAL- RATHER NOT
ADDITIONAL BUT RATHER SOME VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ITEMS THAT ARE
GREAT NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO AB
EIGHTY. WHICH IS THE- PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU MAY-
PRESENT ON THAT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- EIGHTY EIGHTY OR
THE PARTIAL CONFORMITY TO
FEDERAL TREATMENT OF HERO
PROTECTION PROGRAM FRANCE
TRAILER BILL AND THIS BILL
ALLOWS BUSINESSES THAT RECEIPT
AID HERO PROTECTION PROGRAM OR
KEEP KEEP THE LOAN THAT WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY FORGET IN. UP TO
TWO DEDUCT UP TO ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND OF EXPENSES
RELATED TO THE FORGET ABOUT. IN
ADDITION THIS BILL CONFORMS TO
FEDERAL TREATMENT OF THE
FEDERAL ECONOMIC INJURY
DISASTER LOANS I DON'T- ADVANCE
BROWN'S DIFFERENTLY ALLOWING I
DON'T ADVANCED GRANTS NOT TO BE
TAXED AND ALLOWING
DEDUCTIBILITY FOR ANY EXPENSES.
RELATED TO THE GROUND. THIS IS
A PARTIAL. CAN YOU THAT OUR TAX
TREATMENT AND ALLOW HER TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL ON A ALL.
THAT HAD KEEPING YOU LOANS
FORGIVEN- HOWEVER WITH FOCUS ON
THE SMALLER BUSINESS. SO ALL
THAT TOOK OUT A HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR LESS WOULD BE A TO MAKE.
THEIR DUCKS FOR STATE. THANK
YOU I'M HAPPY TO QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE I WILL SEE IF ANY MAN
OF AND THEN OF FOR YOU IN ALLOW
ME TO RECORD YU- SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I ALSO
WANT TO- SUPPORT OF- EIGHTY
EIGHTY- I KNOW THAT- THERE ARE
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES THAT-
TOOK PPP LOANS AND- USE THOSE
FUNDS TO HELP KEEP THE PAYROLL
GOING EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
TECHNICALLY WASN'T ACTUALLY
ENOUGH WORK- FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE OF- THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS THAT WE HAD
TO- TRY TO LIMIT THE SPREAD THE
CORONA VIRUS SO MANY BUSINESSES
REQUIRED TO- CUT BACK THEIR
OPERATIONS OR SHUT DOWN
ALTOGETHER AND- THE PURPOSE OF
THE PDP LOANS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WERE TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS CREATION WORK TO TRY
TO HELP BUSINESSES. CONTINUE TO
PAYROLLS IN FACT YOU HAD TO
SPEND AT LEAST 60% OF THE MONEY
ON PAYROLL ITSELF- NOT A ANY
OTHER EXPENSES AND OTHE
EXPENSES ARE LIMITED TO THINGS
LIKE RENT UTILITIES SO IT'S
VERY NARROWLY CONSTRAIN AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT-
THAT WE DON'T SENSATIONALIZE
BUSINESSES TO ACTUALLY TOOK WHO
WHO GOT THESE LOANS AND EVEN
TOOK THE STEP TO PERHAPS
CONTINUE THEIR EMPLOYEES ON
THEIR PAYROLL WHEN THE
ALTERNATIVE WOULD HAVE BEEN
JUST A HALF HOUR LATER MAS AND
HAVE THEM- PLANET BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO REVENUE BEING GENERATED.
AND MIGHT HAVE NOT EVEN BEEN-
SUFFICIENT WORK- THAT AND THAT
MADE SENSE FOR THEM TO DO THIS
IF THEY HAD NO SUPPORT SO I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP IS MY ONE QUESTION FOR
FINANCES IS THAT DAY- THAT IT
SAID THAT THE BILL'S ESTIMATED
COST ABOUT FIFTY MILLION AND
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND THEN. ONE
POINT ONE BILLION AND THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR- I KNOW THAT MANY
SMALL. WILL BE FINE THEIR- SO
IF YOU'RE AN S. CORP OR YOU'RE
A PARTNERSHIP YOU'RE FILING
YOUR TAX RETURNS ARE DUE ON
MARCH FIFTEENTH- SO LITTLE
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE OF US WHO
ARE FILING- OUR PERSONAL
INTERNS ARE C. CORPORATIONS.
WILL TURN APRIL FIFTEENTH- WILL
BUSINESSES BE ABLE TO ASSUMING
THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNS THIS-
IN A TIMELY MANNER- WILL THIS.
DEDUCTION BE APPLICABLES TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY- STATE TAX
RETURNS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES IF
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR- AND IT
YEAH BEFORE THAT DEADLINE.
THANK GOD FOR HER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- DEPARTMENT MANAGER
FULLY. YES AND THE READ FOR THE
URGE. AND INCLUDE THIS IN THE
MEDIA PACKAGES REALLY TO
PROVIDE BUSINESSES WOULD BE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY WOULD
NEED TO FILE- AND SO IN AND
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION THAT IS
THAT IS THE GOAL. OKAY AND JUST
TO **** QUICK FOLLOW UP-
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE
EXTENT OF THE MOST OF THESE
COSTS RELATE TO THIS IS A
TRIBUTE TO THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR AS THE
REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE HE
EXPECTED WILL BE TURNING IT
OVER OR- PEOPLE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF IT FOR THIS- FOR
THIS TAX RETURN WHICH WILL
APPLY TO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIFTY. SO CAN YOU JUST CLARIFY.
THE TINY OF. TWENTY SPENT ON
THE COST WOODLAND. TO CLARIFY-
WE HAVE. MILLION FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR AND HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION JUSTIFY. IN TERMS
NUMBERS WHAT WE BELIEVE THAT
TO. BUT WILL TURN IT QUESTION
OVER TO OUR TECH EXPERTS
CHAMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LET ME CALL ON SEN- SORRY
DOCTOR. YOU HAVE SOME ELSE.
HELLO HE'S CALL A COCA GOOD.
MORNING THIS IS ENDED SUBJECT
WITH FINE- THIS SENATOR PAN TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT THE
REVENUE IN THE CURRENT- THE
REVENUE LOSS EXPECT TO BE A
REAL LOW IN THAT THE WE DO
EXPECT MOST THESE THIS WILL BE
A LOSS TO BE FISCAL CENTRIFUGE.
LOS CARRY THAT THEY DON'T
NINETY HERE'S. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE COLOR. I WILL GO
TO SENATOR MELINDA FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR CASKEY SAID MELINDA.
YEAH INDICATE YOUR NAME AND YOU
CAN- BUT- HE SAID LYNN THIS
YEAR THANK ITEMS. I'M I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT BILL TODAY AND IT'S
SORELY NEED BUT I MEAN CARRY AS
TO. CALIFORNIA DIDN'T FOLLOW.
THE GOVERNMENT IN MAKING THESE
LINES A 100% DEDUCT AS A TO
WORD- IN THE STOCK YOU. ENTER
OUR SPEAK DIRECTLY. YEAH GOING
TO FINANCE AND MALIAH AM THE
REAL IS- THE COST AND WE A-
HUNDRED CONFORMITY FOUR
BILLION- OVER SIXTY. AND SAID
IS SOMETHING THAT WE- BELIEVE
IT COULD AFFORD AND ALSO
TARGETS THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT BEEN MOST IMPACTED- BY THE
END OF. OKAY THANK YOU IN EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE PRETTY. TO HAVE A
SURPLUS IT'S STILL THE COST. IS
TOO GREAT TO BEAR. ZACKS YES I
THINK THAT THE PACKAGE IS TO-
WHICH PROVIDE AND AT A OF
NINETY SIXTY TO HELP- A VARIETY
OF POPULATION- YES. HE SURE
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU THINK YOU
MANAGER. FIVE THANK YOU SEVERAL
IN THE CENTER OR WHITE HOUSE.
OUR IN SUPPORT OF BILL I THINK
A LOT OF. A CALIFORNIA'S
AMERICA SEVEN THAT WHEN YOU
SOMEBODY YOUR DEBT THAT A TAX.
EVENT I THINK I WANT TO APPLAUD
THE DISTINGUISH GENTLEMAN SO. I
THINK BECAUSE- PEOPLE WERE HURT
SO MUCH ECONOMICALLY THAT THEIR
ACCOUNT EXECUTIVES SAY CARRY
OVER THAT LOSS AND TAKE IT THIS
YEAR ISSUE IF YOUR BILL. IS
YOUR BUSINESS COMES OUT SO THAT
WILL FEEL THAT ECONOMICALLY. IT
WITH- THE TAX RECEIPTS IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR SO IT IT MAKES
SENSE AND YES IT WOULD BE NICE
TO GIVE EVERYBODY ONE BY THAT.
BUT THE LINE HAS BEEN DRAWN
SOMEWHERE I THOUGHT THAT THAT
WAS CLEVER AND- TO PUT IT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WHICH IS
REALLY GOING TO HELP ABOUT THE
CENTER. HEY UNDER FIFTY K.
UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND RIGHT. R.
THREE THOUSAND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR WHITE HOUSE LIMITS IF
THERE'S A OTHER OR COMMENTS-
SENATOR NIELSEN. YES IF I MAY
DIRECT TO FINANCE. THE THIS
BUDGET IS GOING TO BE CREATING
LONG TERM OBLIGATIONS TO
UNDOCUMENTED. WE KNOW AS WE ARE
SITTING HERE THAT TENS OF
THOUSANDS ARE MARCHING TO AN
ACROSS THE BORDERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES. IT
DOES IT CONCERN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THESE NEW
NUMBERS. AND THE BENEFITS
PROVIDED THEIR TO A REALLY
GOING TO BE HARMFUL ON OUR
BUDGET. AT THE LEAST I WOULD
SUGGEST THE ADMINISTRATION NOT.
TAKE ANY ACCOUNT FOR EXTRA
MONEY. WHATEVER THAT IS
SEVENTEEN BILLION OR WHATEVER.
BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO BE
EATEN UP BY THE NEW OBLIGATIONS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE LONG
TERM INCURRING. THE NEW
INDIVIDUALS RESIDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY TAKE HAVE
YOU TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY NUMBERS
ANTICIPATED. THAT YOU'RE BASING
OUR BUDGET ON NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE NEWLY-
DECEPTIVE NOT CITIZENS BUT-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NOT
CITIZENS BUT WE WILL BE
PROVIDING SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS
DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS. OF HOW
MANY YOU EXPECT. HOLD OFF FOR A
MOMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SENATOR NIELSEN THAT
QUESTIONS NOT RELEVANT TO THE
ITEMS THAT WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW
OKAY- I WILL ALLOW DIFFERENT
FINANCE TO ANSWER TO IT BUT IF
THEY DO NOT HAVE SUCH DATA
BEFORE THEM I AM NOT GOING TO
HOLD THEM TO THAT RIGHT NOW
SINCE IT IS NOT. THE ITEM THAT
WE ARE HEARING AT THE MOMENT
NINE. AND SENATOR NELSON WEEKLY
DON'T HAVE THOSE THOSE NUMBERS-
BUT I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
THAT- THE INCREASE IN REVENUES
IS ONE TIME. AND WE'RE BEING
VERY CAREFUL OF HOW WE SPEND
THOSE- THAT THOSE SURPLUS
DOLLARS. BURKE SEEING NO OTHER
<c.green>OMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE WILL</c>
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT. BILL WHICH
IS AB EIGHTY ONE. TEN AB EIGHTY
ONE. IS- GENERAL FEDERAL
RELIEF- AND IT IS- VARIOUS
THINGS TO GET CONFORMITY WITH
SOME OF THE FEDERALS SO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU GO
AHEAD. THEY'RE CALLING WITH THE
DEPARTENT OF FINANCE- AB
EIGHTY ONE OR THE GENERAL
FEDERAL RELIEF AND CLEANUP
TRAILER BILL- THIS BILL
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT- CAL EITC.
ANTHONY GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
FOR OUTREACH. IT ALSO WAVES THE
THIRTEEN WEEK PERIOD IN THE
FEDERAL STATE EXTENDED DURATION
WHICH IS ALSO THE FED AD
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
AFTER REGULAR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS HAVE BEEN
EXHAUSTED. IT ALSO. AT THE
READY TO EXPAND. TO THE CALPERS
PROGRAM BY DISREGARDING ENDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME FROM
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS FOR
COWARDS APPLICANTS IT IS
ALREADY DISREGARDED FOR CURRENT
RECIPIENTS- AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO FUND ITS EXPANSION-
AND LASTLY THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE RECENT
EVICTION MORATORIUM EXTENSION
AND STATE EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM UNDER SB
NINETY ONE- TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
NRB EIGHT FOR THE ARE ANY I
WANT TO DO A REMINDER TO. SAID
THE L. A. ALL THROUGH A BILL.
TO ANSWER QUESTION YOU MIGHT
HAVE. SO SEEING NO- QUESTION ON
FACT CENTER GOING. KAMALA A ROW
IN SOME BUT IT HAVE A- RELATED
TO THE ITEM- IT MAY BE A LITTLE
THINLY RELATED BUT I THOUGHT
THIS IS THE EST TIME TO ASK IN
TERMS OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
AND WHAT THE QUESTION IS HAS TO
DO WITH THE CARD DISCUSSION
COURSE ICE- BY VOTED FOR SB
NINETY ONE IN. A IN SOME OF THE
PART OF BUDGET. DISCUSSIONS THE
BUDGET HEARING ON THE ITEM-
THERE WERE SOME ENQUIRIES MADE
BY ME- BY OTHERS WITH REGARD
TO- LEGAL ASSISTANCE THAT WOULD
BE COMING OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE LANDLORD
TENANT ITEM. I'M REALLY JUST
WANTED TO SPENDING MORE
PROGRESS WITH THAT- IN IF
THERE'S ANY- A- NEWS OR OR
POTENTIAL- FOR CALL CENTER-
LEGAL ASSISTANCE IN AND
MEDIATION SERVICES TO BE-
PRIORITIZE BY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IN CONNECTION-
WITH- THIS BILL I KNOW THESE
ARE CLEAN UP ITEMS TECHNICAL
ITEMS ONLY AND IT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE INCLUDED-
LANGUAGE LIKE THIS IN IN AB
EIGHTY ONE BUT I DO THINK THAT-
THAT. CONTINUING NEED AS I CALL
IT IS AT LEAST RELATED TO THE
ITEM SO JUST LOOKING FOR
PROGRESS. GO AHEAD BERMAN
FINANCE YES EXACTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THIS IS
TECHNICALLY OF A DOZEN INCLUDE
A MONIES- BUT I WOULD POINT TO-
TWENTY MILLION IN LEGAL AID
THAT- PRIOR BUDGET- ALLOCATED
FOR LEGAL AID AND I WILL TRN
TO MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS COOK FOR
SOME DETAILS ON THE STATUS OF
THOSE- DOLLARS. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATORS SO AS AS MISLI
INDICATED- DIGICEL COUNCIL HAS-
TWENTY MILLION THAT WAS A IN
GENERAL FUND IT WAS
APPROPRIATED TWO YEARS AGO THAT
STILL AVAILABLE FOR LEGAL AID-
IN ADDITION. THIS LAST YEAR
THERE WAS THIRTY ONE MILLION
AND A NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT FUNDS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY FOR LEGAL AID. FOR
RENTERS- AND SO THAT THIRTY ONE
MILLION IS ALSO AVAILABLE FOR
THEM TO DO LEGAL LIKE SERVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS. FOLLOW UP
QUESTION OF IRAN AND IS HE CAN
I CAN WE GET- AND IN OFFLINE.
WOULD BE FINE- AFTER TODAY IT
INFORMATION ON ON HOW. HI
COUNTIES PARTICULARLY THOSE
COUNTIES THAT- ESSENTIALLY ARE
IN THEIR OWN WITH NINE OR TEN
OF MONEY- IN THE SENSE OF
POPULATION. OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CITIES AND
COUNTIES HOW THEY WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT MONEY I JUST
DON'T I DON'T KNOW THE
MECHANICS I DON'T. WANT TO STOP
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS TO. GET
INTO THAT TOO DEEPLY BUT I
SUSPECT THAT- I'M NOT THE ONLY.
SENATE OFFICER WILL BE
INTERESTED IN PASSING THAT
INFORMATION ALONG- TO OUR
LOCALS AND DISTRICTS. YES
SENATOR WE CAN GET SOME
INFORMATION TO YOU THANK YOU
THE THEY CAN MANAGER THANK YOU
LET ME GO TO SENATOR MELENDEZ
HAHA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR MARINE MOMENT SENATOR
MELINDA THREE UP TO BE ON THE
SCREEN OKAY GO AHEAD NOW. EACH
YEAR I'M SO THIS BILL THE MAIN
A YEAR THE TURNING IN WHICH DAN
WOULD BE NEEDED BE REPAID
MILLION WHICH RESULTS FURTHER.
PROVIDING THE IN ORDER I NEED
RELIEF FROM THE WEREN'T. IT IS
NOW GOING BE EXT TO ALL NEXT
YEAR NO THIS DEFINITELY
CURRENTLY ORIGINAL- CURIOUS
POSITION I'M MORE. PERHAPS THE
ONLY KNOW- AND FINANCE COULD
RISE IN COMING TO ASKED WHAT
TYPE AND. INSULARITY PACKAGE
HOW HONOR- AND IN ORDER WORKS
FINE SITUATION THANK YOU.
MORTGAGE OWNERS. YES THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SO THE DATE
CHANGE THAT YOU DO SEE IN THE
LANGUAGE WAS PURELY A DRAFTING
ERROR THAT UNDER THE AGREEMENT
UNDER THE ORIGINAL SB NINETY
ONE AUGUST- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DATE WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE
THAT DATE- SO JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT DAY IF IT'S NOT- WE'RE NOT
MAKING A SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE
SURE THAT'S JUST KIND OF A
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO CONFORM TO
THE AGREEMENT- AND- THAT
LEGISLATION- AS TO THE EFFECT
ON THE ECONOMY I DON'T THINK I
DON'T HAVE A RESPONSE OR ERROR-
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
ANALYSIS HAS BEEN DONE AT THIS
TIME I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES EITHER THROUGH
THE ALLEY- OR- AT FINANCE HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY BUT I DON'T
THINK AN INDEX- ANALYSIS HAS
BEEN DONE ON THE EFFECTIVE THAT
MORATORIUM EXTENSION. I WONDER
DOES THE L. A. I DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS. HELLO. YES
SENATOR MELINDA IS THIS IS-
GAVE PATRICK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE- I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT TO ADD
AT THIS TIME ON THIS BUT W
WOULD BE HAPPY TO- CONFER WITH
YOUR OFFICE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY SPECIFIC- QUESTIONS WE
COULD EXPLORE ANY ADDITIONAL
WORK WE COULD DO ON YOUR BEHALF.
WILL BE GREATER SHOULD WOULD
PERHAPS YOU DON'T. BUT I THINK
IT'S ARM SOMETHING KNOW WE HAVE
TO CONSIDER. AS A WHOLE ONE
WE'RE TALKING HOW GOING TO ALEX.
FUNDING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU. LET ME SEE
THERE'S ANY OTHER. FIVE FIFTEEN
NINE. WE WILL NOW GO TO THE-
NEXT BILL WHICH IS AB EIGHTY
TWO ON THE MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES THEY ARE TELLING
ME THAT THE LIQUID DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AB EIGHT TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BILL-
DISTILLERY. AND THAT WAS
REACHED ON SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION SEIU.
EARNING EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO ASSIST WITH CONTACT
TRACING. IT ALSO RATIFIED AN
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BETWEEN THE STATE AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED OR C. CPU
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN- MAKE. MY LAST IT
UP MOMENTS FOR INTO MALE
FOUNDER CROWN VIRUS RESPONSE
AND REALLY SUB ACT OR KRESA
FUNDS HUMANE KERR CHILD SERVICE
REDUCE CLOSURES AND ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDA- WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
BIRDS DOLLY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE MANAGER JUST REAL QUICK
IS THAT ONLY AFFECT SEIU
MEMBERS ARE IS THAT ON THE
CHILD CARE PART I UNDERSTAND
THAT- BASICALLY THE LANGUAGE
THEY WERE INTERPRETING IN THE
LIKES OF WHICH IS BASICALLY
OVER ABOVE THEIR NORMAL JOB BUT
IS IT ONLY AFFECTED US YEAH YOU
OR DOES IT AFFECT OTHER- DGS
WORKERS THAT WERE THERE ARE AT
THE CHILD CARE AS WELL. AFTER
THE FIRST. POINT WAS OVER.
BETWEEN THE STATE AND AT THE I
USE- CHILD CARE WORKERS STATE-
WORKERS ON IN. UNITS
1-341-114-1517 TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MEASURE. YOUR THAT- BUT
THEY TRY CARE- RATIFICATION WAS
SEPARATE. SO I GUESS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ALL I DON'T KNOW THE
BAR YOU WHO IT WAS INCLUDED ALL
THE BASICALLY PEOPLE WORK FOR
THE GUY. OR IS EXCLUDE- SO I
DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER. AND
SENATOR I'M GONNA TURN QUESTION
FOR MORTGAGE TO MY CALL MERRY
HOW. A MERRY HOW TO READ THE-
BRAIN. YES THEY WOULD COME ALL
AND- OR- BY I SEE. I'M AN
ADDITIONAL WE ALREADY. IN A-
WITH OTHER PARTY UNITS OUTSIDE
OF I SEE ARE YOU THOSE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH WITH THIS. A FORMAL.
WE JUST HAVE TO NOTICE AND THE
LEGISLATURE THOSE. AND OTHERS
AND- NOT. BY SEIU ARE ALSO
COVERED. AND SO THEY DIDN'T TO
WORK DIDN'T. I GUESS THE OTHER
BAR IN UNISON NONE OF. WERE
WHERE THEY ARE DON'T KNOW THAT
TERM LIKE WE YOU'RE- OPEN ABOUT
YOUR- DO LIKE I KNOW THAT. A
LOT OF THOSE WERE INTER. THAT
WERE CALLED IN- BUT THE OTHER
PART DIDN'T DO OR- HAVE A
DIFFERENT- WAY OF GOING A IT I
GUESS IS MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
HE- NOT. NOT ONE BY UNIT GOT. A
LEG UP ANOTHER. BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDED THE SERVICES WE NEED.
RIGHT SO I AM. THE OTHER PARTY
UNITS REYES- OUT OF CLAY HEY I
THINK THE TERM THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING YOUR. I'M PLEASED THAT
WERE BELOW THAT ARE DOWN LEVEL
AND THEY'RE RECEIVING ACROSS
OUT THAT LEVEL- AND THEN THE I
COME. IS PILING K. IF THEY ARE
PROVIDING BILINGUAL SERVICES
THROUGH THEIR CON RAISING
LAYMEN THEY WOULD RISK THEM
OKAY. YEAH BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR OFFICE IDENTIFIED ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND CHILD CARE CENTERS
THAT ARE PERMANENTLY CLOSED
WHICH MEANS THERE'S ABOUT.
ROUGHLY EVERY THIRTY THOUSAND
CHILD CARE SLOTS THAT NOW NO
LONGER EXISTING WE HAVE KIND OF
RE PURPOED- SEPTEMBER STATE
EMPLOYEES FOR OTHER PURPOSES SO.
DO WE SEE A NATION HERE WHERE
PERHAPS- WE HAVE SOME OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS ARE OVERSTAFFED IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO THEN YOU KNOW
SHIFT THESE WORKERS TO ANOTHER
ROLE INSTEAD. WE HAVE AN ISSUE
HERE WHERE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SEEN OVER STAFFING. HI THURMOND
AS VICTOR CABRAL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
THINK THAT THE SHOCKER BECAUSE
YOU'RE DOING THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE HEARD ABOUT THAT.
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE IS THE
ENTIRE- CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
SUBSIDIZE AND UNSUBSIDIZED TO
THE CONCERNED HI BACK TO OUR
PROVIDERS THAT MAY BE A RISKY
BECAUSE THAT'S BECAUSE- WE-
DON'T. DIRECTLY THE TO THE
AMOUNT OF- THESE ARE- A GLAZER
THE THINGS THE R. R. UNFUNDED
I'M SEE TO THIS I THINK. SEEN
THAT AS A THE OF THE- PROVIDERS
AVAILABLE. FAMILY THAT RECEIVE
VOUCHERS ARE. IN ORDER TO- TO
BE ABLE TO FIND. I BELIEVE
DON'T THINK THAT'S A NEED FOR
THERE'S RESPECT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR. OKAY. JUST SO CLEAR IF
WE HAVE A NUMBER STATE WHO WORK
BEING SHIFTED TO DO EITHER GIVE-
IT IS SOMETHING IS NOT THERE
IT'S NOT SUFFERING. PERHAPS WE
ARMS. MANY PEOPLE WITHIN
DEPARTMENT WITH THE UPSTAIRS
SUGAR YOU THINK THE THIS. NOT
NECESSARY THE CASE. ARAMBULA
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO TALK
PROVIDER CHAKRA PROVIDERS AND
IN A NY- ARE. THE THIRD COULD
HAVE BEEN A THEM THE BARGAINING
SORT OF MORE RECENT ACTIVITY
BUT IT IS ON THE ARE FAMILIES
CARE HOME PROVIDERS ON BE
OFFERING OWN. THEIR OWN
BUSINESS THERE'S A SIMMERING
OUT THOSE ARE NOT I THINK THE
CATEGORY OF STEPHEN. ARE MORE
PRONE BECAUSE BUT FOR GOING TO
SLEEP. IT THANK YOU THINK
MEDICARE. THANK YOU. SEEING
ORDERS I WILL TO. AB EIGHTY
THREE. AND THIS IS THE SMALL
LICENSING FEE EXEMPTIONS AND AS
I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING THE
TOTAL PACKAGE OF BUSINESS
RELIEF THAT WE ARE PROVIDING IN
THESE BILLS IT'S FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION N. P. D. THIS BE
LICENSING EXEMPTION IS PART OF
THAT PACKAGE FOR GO AHEAD- TO
DEAL WITH PRESENT ON AB EIGHTY
THREE. THEY'RE CALLING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- EIGHTY
THREE SMALL BUSINESS LICENSING
EXEMPTIONS TRAILER BILL. THIS
BILL INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION IN GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME LICENSE
RENEWAL FEE WAIVERS TO ALL
LICENSEES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY-
THESE LICENSES WOULD INCLUDE
COSMETOLOGISTS BARBERS
MANICURISTS ESTHETICIANS A LOT
OF CHALLENGES- ANY
ESTABLISHMENTS WHERE THESE
REGULATED SERVICES ARE PROVIDED.
I DON'T HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE YOU
TIME LICENSE RENEWAL FEE
WAIVERS IN TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO FOR CERTAIN
LICENSEES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL-
PRIMARILY BARS AND RESTAURANTS.
IF I THINK THE RENEWAL WAIVERS
ARE TARGETED AT INDIVIDUALS AND
SMALLER ENTITIES. THAT HAVE
BEEN HEAVILY IMPACTED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY RESTRICTIONS-
IMPOSING RESPONSIBLE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION. FOR IT
SENATOR Y. CHARACTER. THANK
MANAGER I THE BARBERS AND CUT
COLLEGES CAUSE TWENTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION I DIDN'T GET
IT WHAT THE ABC- BUDGET- FISCAL
EFFECT IS GOING TO HAVE ON THE
BUDGET WITH THE THAT THAT.
WAIVER OF FEES. I HAD A
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE ANY
GERMAN THANK YOU. IN THE
SERVICE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THAT THE COST FOR THE ABC
LICENSE FEES IS NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT WAS ACTUALLY
AGAIN BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WHICH
WAS PART OF AB EIGHTY FIVE SO
DID BILL AND- EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE INCLUDES AN APPROPRIATION
JUST TO BACK FILL THE- BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AT THE AMOUNT
OF TWENTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS BUT BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR WHICH WAS HEARD
PREVIOUSLY INCLUDES THE NINETY
MILLION. COURTESY OTHER
AT OUR REMOTE FOLKS OKAY NINE
ALL RIGHT- WE WILL THEN MOVE ON
TO. AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS AND- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YOU MAY PRESENT.
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- AB EIGHTY EIGHT OR THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TRAILER
BILL THIS BILL PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS MANY WHO HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED BY
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF COULD BE
NINETEEN- THE PANDEMIC. THREE
SIX HUNDRED TAX THIRTY SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX REFUND TO
ALL TWENTY TWENTY- CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS TO ALL
TWENTY TWENTY I. TEN FILERS
WITH INCOME UNDER SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND- I TO FILERS ALSO
QUALIFY FOR THE EITC FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TAX YEAR WILL
RECEIVE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS-
AND ALSO PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS- IN ONE TIME GRANTS
PAYMENTS TO HOUSEHOLDS ENROLLED
IN THE CALYX PROGRAM AND
RECIPIENTS OF EXERCISE. AT THIS
P. AND KATHY- AS I STATED
EARLIER AND THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ACTUALLY INCLUDES THE
DOLLARS ARE RELATED TO THE
POWER. SUPPLY S. S. P. AND
CAPPY- TRANCE. THE BILL ALSO
REPEAL REQUIRE- I DOT AT THE OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION FOR THE APPLE TV- TO
PRODUCE A PLAN FOR TAX DODGERS
AND CONSOLE. WITH FINANCE AND
THE STATE TREASURER- I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
CAN BE I. RECOGNIZE SO. SOME OF
MY- SIDE WANTED MAKE A PEEP. ON
THIS. I AM VERY VERY. PLEASED
THAT THIS PACKAGE THIS GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS CAME TOGETHER
AND THAT IT IS COME TOGETHER AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WHICH IS
PRIOR TO MOST PEOPLE HAVING YET
FILED. FOR THEIR TWENTY TWENTY
ARE THERE TWENTY NINETEEN. BUT
TAXES. AND TWENTY TWENTY SORRY
WE'RE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TAXES. AND I WILL
NOTE THAT THE- THE GOVERNOR'S
GREAT ANNOUNCEMENT IN EARLY IN
DECEMBER OR EARLY JANUARY WITH
THIS CONCEPT. AT THAT POINT WAS
GOING TO BASE THE E. I. T. C.
ON TWENTY NINETEEN FILERS. BUT
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN OF COURSE IS
THERE. ARE SOME FOLKS WHO WERE.
OKAY IN TWENTY NINETEEN HAVE
ARE NOW. QUALIFY FOR EITC
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF THEIR
JOBS IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE OF REDUCTION IN HOURS
OR OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES. BEYOND
WHAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS IS
FURTHER UNEMPLOYMENT BY MANY OF
OUR LOW WAGE WORKERS SEVERAL
FURTHER STRESS ON DAY AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AS SEEN BY THE
DEMANDS ON OUR FOOD BANKS AND
OTHERS. SO I REALLY I'M REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THIS HAS COME
TOGETHER AND THAT WE HAVE SUCH
A ROBUST PACKAGE FOR THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE THE LEAST
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW. AND I ALSO
WOULD NOTE THAT WHILE THERE
WERE SOME COMMENT ABOUT IN
IMMIGRANTS THAT. THE L. A. O.
IN THEIR OWN RECOMMENDATIONS IN
TERMS OF HOW WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT. THE INAPPROPRIATE
STIMULUS USING STATE MONEY IS
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK TO TARGET
THOSE RESIDENTS WHO DID NOT
BENEFIT FROM THE FEDERAL
STIMULUS AND THAT IS IN MANY
PARTS WHAT THIS DOES AND IN
THAT IT ALLOWS FOR THOSE BY TEN
FILERS FOR FOLKS TO PAY TAXES
BUT MAY NOT BE. ELIGIBLE FOR
THE OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS IT
ALLOWS THEM TO BENEFIT FROM
THIS GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS AND
THIS IS ONE TIME ONLY THIS IS
NOT ONGOING IT IS NOT LONG TERM
THE ONLY ON GOING ITEMS IN THE
ENTIRE ALL THE BILLS WE ARE
CONSIDERING THIS THE
RESTORATION TO OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGETS IN A COUPLE
OF OTHER THINGS BUT THIS
PARTICULAR. STIMULUS TO
INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA IS ONE
TIME AND ONE TIME ONLY AND WITH
THAT LET ME SEE I SEE SENATOR
DRAWS SO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I TO RISE TO
SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTY EIGHT- AND
THE WHOLE PACKAGE OF. IT'S A
THE THOUGHT THAT WENT INTO
FOCUSING ON THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
HAD THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES I WE COULD
JUST GO ON AND ON WITH WITH THE
LIST OF THOSE WHO ARE BEING
TARGETED- AS HAVING THE LEAST.
OF SUPPORT NOW GETTING THE
SUPPORT HAT THEY NEED AS
CALIFORNIANS- I'M VERY PLEASED
ABOUT THE B. I. T. C. AS WELL-
AND EXPANDING TO MORE LOW
INCOME WORKERS- ESPECIALLY IF
THERE WERE INELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL RELIEF- I THINK IT'S A
GREAT STEP FORWARD IT'S AND
THEN ALL KNOWLEDGE MENT. OF ALL
THESE LOW WAGE WORKERS WHO ARE
LOW WAGES NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO BE RECEIVING LOW WAGES BUT
THEY ARE WORKING HARD OR THEY
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY.
IMPACTED WITH THROUGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND OTHERWISE LIKE
IN THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY.
ALL WOULD BE WORKING- AND JUST
OVERNIGHT LOST THEIR JOBS SO
I'M I'M PLEASE WITH THAT I
THINK- THERE'S ROOM TO INCLUDE
MORE. OF A WHOLE OUR WAR STILL
NOT COVERED EITHER BY OUR STATE
OR BY THE FEDERAL AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING AND
CONTINUING TO GO IN THAT
DIRECTION THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WITH A CENTER
GROVE. I'M THINKING PRESIDENT I
AS I JUST HAVE A QUESTION ON
THE ACCOUNT WORKS THE CALVERTS
SUPPLEMENTAL INCOME THAT'S
GOING TO BE GIVEN TO CALVERT'S
RECIPIENTS- I WASN'T AWARE THAT
ANY STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
ALL OF US AND THOSE KIND OF
PROGRAMS WERE INTERRUPTED SO
WERE THOSE PROGRAMS INTERRUPTED
WHERE THEY DIDN'T RECEIVE THOSE
FUNDS. AND THERE'S A NECESSITY
TO BACK FILL A MONEY THAT THEY
DID NOT RECEIVE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT. I'M SURE I'LL START AN
ENEMY HANDED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION- THE- THE PROGRAM THE
CALPERS PROGRAM WASN'T
NECESSARILY INTERRUPTED I THINK
THAT THIS IS A KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THAT THE PEOPLE RECIPIENTS- ON
CAL WORKS HAVE BEEN. NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED TO THE PANDEMIC AND TO
PROVIDE- CASH ASSISTANCE TO
THEM CASUALLY- ON TOP OF. THAT
HOW WORKS GRANT THEY'RE
RECEIVING. SO IT ABSENT THE
PANDEMIC THEY WOULD HAVE STILL
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS THAT THEY
HAD BEEN RECEIVING THE ENTIRE
TIME THROUGH THE PANDEMIC- CAN
YOU JUST- ELABORATE ON WHAT
THEY LOST AND HOW THEY WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED IF
THEY CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
ENTIRE BENEFIT. IT WAS
ALLOCATED TO THEM PRE PANDEMIC-
YES AND I THINK I WOULD JUST GO
BACK TO MY COMMENTS AND IN
pREGARDS TO- THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS- THE FELT BY
CALIFORNIANS IT'S BEEN THOSE AT
THE LOWEST INCOME- THAT HAVE
BEEN MORE IMPACTED. AND SO THIS
IS A KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT- BABY
NEED ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE. SO
ARE YOU I STILL AM NOT CLEAR I
GUESS AND I DON'T I DON'T NEED
TO BELABOR THE POINT I'M JUST
SAYING THAT I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT CALL MY OFFICE
THAT. HAVE LOST THEIR JOB- AND
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SOME OF
THEM HAVE MOVED IN WITH OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS OR- MOVED OUT OF
THE HOUSE OF THEIR THEIR
APARTMENT THEY WERE RENTING.
AND THEY'RE NOT CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT ALL CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS JUST LIKE ALL OF US
AND EVERY GOVERNMENT WORKER.
DID NOT MISS ONE PAYCHECK I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR- THEIR DICK I'M MY
CONCERN IS I GUESS WE'RE
ALLOCATING SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR CALYXT RECIPIENTS. BUT I
WASN'T AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
ANY OF THE RESOURCES HAD BEEN
INTERESTED IN ANY TIME. SURE
AND- AT THE GRANTS MAY NOT HAVE
CHANGED BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
MANY HAVE LOST JOBS AND YOU
KNOW IT. CAN WORKS OF
RECIPIENTS ALSO WORK. AND MANY
OF THEM MAY HAVE LOST JOBS AS
WELL AND SO HAVE REDUCED
INCOMES- IN IN. IN RESPONSE TO.
YOUR COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU
MA'AM. AND SENATOR GROUPS I
COULD ADDRESS THAT- YOU'RE
CORRECT THERE'S BEEN NO
INTERRUPTION AS THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE REFERENCED BUT CAL
WORKS DOES HAVE A WORK
REQUIREMENT. HOWEVER MANY OF
THOSE FAMILIES COWORKERS
APPEARANCE MANY OF WHOM WERE-
SINGLE WOMEN. SINGLE MOTHERS
WITH CHILDREN. THEN DID ALSO
NOT HAVE THEIR CHILD CARE SO
THEY- SOMETIMES WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO GO TO WORK SO THEY LOST THE
INCOME OF THAT WORK FOR THEY
HAD THOSE HOURS REDUCED FOR
ADDITIONALLY. THEIR CHILDREN
MAY HAVE GOTTEN. THEIR MEALS
THREE SCHOOL BUT WITH SCHOOLS
CLOSED. DOWN ARE NOT. BEING FED
THROUGH SCHOOL PUTTING AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON THE
HOUSEHOLD. SO THAT IS- ONE OF
THE RATIONALES FOR HELPING
THOSE FAMILIES WHO WORK ON THE
COVERAGE RECIPIENTS ARE AS YOU
KNOW SOME OF OUR LOWEST INCOME
FAMILIES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FOR THE EXPLANATION I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE WELCOME.
RIGHT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR CASH SENATOR
PAN GO AHEAD. NO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND- AS OF THE
PAST CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES- I THINK- I APPRECIATE
THE EXPLANATION FROM THE CHAIR.
BECAUSE CAL WORKS IS NOT MERELY
A CASH BENEFIT AND I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT WE HAVE WORKED HARD
TO BRING UP TAL WORKS PAYMENTS
FOR. DEEP POVERTY TO TRY TO
DRESS WE'LL TALK ABOUT HALF OF
THE PARTY LEVEL RIGHT TRYING TO
BE SURE WE- HELP THOSE THAT
THERE'S OF- AND- THOSE FAMILIES
WHEN YOU'RE ON POWER TO HAVE A
TIME LIMIT AND WHILE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SUSPEND THAT FOR ALL
THAT YOU'RE REQUIRED TO DO
WORK. OR EDUCATION YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS WE HAD A HEARING ON
THAT SO I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THATNATURE
OF THE BENEFIT STRUCTURES WE
HAVE TO HELP OUT. FAMILIES IN
NEED- HOW BOTH RESTRICTIVE THEY
ARE. BUT ALSOTHE FACT THAT IS
IT AND THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE
CASH IT'S THE OTHER SERVICES
WHICH HAVE ALSO BEEN SUSPENDED
BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS. AND COMBATING THIS- IT'S
PANDEMIC CELEBRATE PRECIADO
CLARIFICATION BUT I JUST WANT
TO REINFORCE THAT. AND I THINK
THIS IS A RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE FULL BENEFITS. AND
CAL WORKS WHICH IS NOT JUST THE
CASH BENEFIT BUT THE OTHER
THINGS BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND. SO I WOULD URGE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO SEEING
NO OTHER COM YOUR QUESTION- I
WILL NOTE. THAT BEFORE WE GO
TO- ARE. LAST ITEM WHICH IS A
HEARING ITEM THAT- ADDITIONALLY
THERE IS SOME FUNDING IN HERE
TO AUGMENT WE HAVE WE HAVE. IN
OUR ON GOING BUDGET PROVIDED
SOME FUNDING TO PROOTE THE
EITC PROGRAM THANK THE CALLIE
ITC AND THE FEDERAL WITH KELLY
HERE YOU CAN SEE ESPECIALLY SO
THAT WE CAN. GET THE PROPER
TAKE UP IN OUR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS ARE AWARE OF IT AND
THERE IS FINDING HERE AND
AUGMENTATION TO THAT SO THAT WE
CAN GET THE WORD OUT AND- I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND THAT ALL OF US%
THROUGH OUR- MECHANISM. TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS GET THAT WORD OUT
BECAUSE- DAYS COULD PROVIDE
SOME GREAT RELIEF TO MANY
FAMILIES THEN SENATOR WAKO
SECURE STANDING UP DID YOU EVER
COME INTO YOU OKAY FINE. ALL
RIGHT SO LET ME THEN GO TO THE-
HEARING THAT STORY THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING PORTION.
OF OUR- BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
THIS IS ON B- FINE SB EIGHTY
SEVEN BUT SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
THE BILL IS NOT BEFORE US
FORMALLY BECAUSE IT IS IN THE
ASSEMBLY- SO OUR- OUR
DISCUSSION OF IT OR ARE HEARING
ON IT. NOW IS FOR THE- EXCUSE
ME ON USE MY PROPER
TERMINOLOGY- THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE BILL SO SENATOR KIRBY ROAD
GO AHEAD BEFORE WE HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF IT S. B. EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
CORPORATE NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM WITHIN THE OFFICE. OF
THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE.
CAL O. S. B. A. TO THIS IS WILL
ASSIST THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF GRANTS
QUALIFIED SMALL BUSINESSES WHO
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED
ECONOMICALLY BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATE TWO POINT OH SEVEN
FIVE BILLION. TO FIND THE
PROGRAM INCLUDING FIFTY MILLION
TO NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. AS WE KNOW SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE CONTINUED TO STRUGGLE. TO
SURVIVE DURING THE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS WE'VE ALL RECEIVED THOSE
PHONE CALLS RECENT DATA
INDICATES THE CLOSE TO ONE
THIRD OF SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
NOT SURVIVE BEYOND THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF THIS YEAR WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. MANY
NONPROFITS HAVE ALSO BEEN
ADVERSELY IMPACTED AS THEIR
RESOURCES AND FINANCES HAVE
DECLINED WHILE THE DEMAND FOR
SERVICES HAS INCREASED. SMALL
BUSINESSES PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S THREE TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY. BUSINESSES WITH
DEADLY WHAT BUSINESSES WITH
LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES MAKE
UP ALMOST 90% OF THE BUSINESSES
AND THOSE WITH LESS THAN A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES REPRESENT
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT. OF ALL
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE AND AS
OF NOVEMBER SMALL BUSINESS
REVENUE WAS DOWN 33% THIS BILL
FORMALLY ESTABLISHES AND
EXPANDS THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS CDE NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT THE
GOVERNOR CREATED THROUGH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TWO MONTHS AGO.
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
GRANTS UP TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO QUALIFIED
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NONPROFIT
MISSION SERVICES. WITH UP TO
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ANNUAL
GROSS REVENUE AND TO ELIGIBLE
NONPROFIT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS SOUS MUSEUMS AND
PERFORMING ARTS COMPANIES WITH
NO LIMITATION ON ANNUAL GROSS
REVENUE. THE BILL SPECIFIED THE
GRANT WOULD BE ALLOCATED ACROSS
AT LEAST FOUR ROUNDS ONE CLOSED
AROUND USING THE EXISTING
APPLICANTS FROM ROUNDS ONE AND
TWO OF THE PREVIOUS CODE
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM.
ONE ROUND FOR ELIGIBLE
NONPROFIT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
AND AT LEAST TWO NEW OPEN
ROUNDS FOR ALL QUALIFIED SMALL
BUSINESSES. GRANT AMOUNTS VARY
BASED ON THE ANNUAL GROSS
INCOME OF THE BUSINESS A FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH UP TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN REVENUE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT WITH
REVENUE BETWEEN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE MILLION. AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT FOR REVENUE OVER ONE
MILLION. AS A COMEDIAN ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE GRANTS PROPOSED
IN THIS BILL ARE SMALL COMPARED
TO THE SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
LOSSES. SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
SUFFERED. MORE ASSISTANCE WILL
BE CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
THESE BUSINESSES ARE ABLE TO
STAY AFLOAT. HOWEVER SB EIGHTY
SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP IN THAT PROCESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FROM
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS BILL. NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO HAND IT OVER TO
FINANCE TO SHARE ADDITIONAL
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. YOUR I'M
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON THAT THANK YOU
CENTER FOR THE EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION I ACTUALLY HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD. ALRIGHT LET'S
SEE IF WE SUMA ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST AM
VERY PLEASED THAT WILL. VERY
PLEASED THAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
THIS NOW AND I GUESS I WAS
ASKED TO MAKE SURE. WELL TO GET
THE WORD OUT AS WE'RE DOING
WITH THE ATC WHAT KIND OF.
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN WE HAVE TO
REACH OUT. TO SOME OF OUR
SMALLER NONPROFITS SMALLER
BUSINESSES. MAY NOT HAVE. THE
NETWORKS TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON AND SO THE BIGGER ONES DON'T
GET AT ALL FIRST. BERMAN
FINANCE DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT. YES AND I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE SOMEBODY
pSANJITA FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO THAT THE ORIGINALLY
THE CDFI THAT WAS- ASSIGNED
THIS IN THE FIRST AND SECOND
ROUND IT'S L'INDUSTRIE IT'S A
CALIFORNIA BASED. OF A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION AND THEY HAVE A
PRETTY ROBUST NETWORK OF
NONPROFITS AND OTHER CITIES
CDFI THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WHERE THEY NETWORK AND THEY
LEVERAGE THEIR CONNECTIONS AND
THE RESOURCES TO REACH THE MOST
VULNERABLE I'M SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT MAY NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
OR THE ABILITY TO. REACH OUT
AND APPLY AND IN THIS PROGRAM
IT IS NOT BASED ON A FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE BASIS ALLEN IT'S
BASED ON- GOING TO ALL THE
APPLICATIONS AND THEN CREATING-
AN ALGORITHM THAT LOOKS AT AT.
THREE DIFFERENT- ACTORS
INCLUDING THE GEOGRAPHIC TO.
BASED ON A CO IN NINETEEN
HEALTH AND SAFETY RESTRICTIONS-
THE INDUSTRY IMPACTS INCLUDING
THE- THE MOST HIGHLY IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES. AS WELL AS- THE
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDERSERVED
GROUPS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO. IT
ISN'T- LEVERAGING ALL THOSE
RESOURCES TO REACH THE MOST
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES THANK YOU.
AND CLEARLY THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE- WE MEMBERS WOULD ALSO.
BE GOOD TO PUT THE WORD OUT
BECAUSE CLEARLY ARE. ARE
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE SMALL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE MY MANY OF
OUR SMALL GREEN BUSINESS GROUPS
WILL BE AWARE AND THEY WILL
SPREAD THE WORD HOWEVER THERE
MAY BE SOME FOR EXAMPLE SMALL
PARTS. ENTITIES OR STAGE
COMPANIES MUSIC VENUES THAT MAY
NOT BE AWARE THAT THEY WOULD
QUALIFY FOR THIS AND WITH THE-
THE FACT WE CALL IT A SMALL
BUSINESS PROGRAM BUT THE
NONPROFIT. ENTITIES ARE
ELIGIBLE AS WELL AS THESE
CULTURAL INSTITUTION SO. OUR
GETTING INFO OUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WILL HELP GET THE
WORD OUT. LET ME FEES IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR NIELSEN GO
AHEAD. THE MANAGER AND MEMBERS
I WANT TO. THANK SENATOR
CAFIERO AND AS WELL- I HAVE TO
MENTION CENTER BORDERS AS THEY
HAVE BEEN PRINCIPLE AUTHORS AND
SB SEVENTY FOUR MANY OF US ARE
COAUTHORS. THE POINT HERE
THOUGH IS. AS EACH DAY GOES BY
MORE OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE GOING OUT OF BUSINESS. AND
THERE YOU HAVE BILL IS NEEDED
TO BE FAST TRACKED. SO THAT WE
CAN GET THEM AT ANOTHER MEDIA
HELP AND HOPE. TO HANG ON FOR A
TIME AS WE WORK OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC DISASTER- THE SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS CONCEPT AND
FOR WHAT SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE
HERE TO TRY TO LET THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES HANG ON CALIFORNIA.
I VISIT A LOT OF THEM AND IT
WENT TO A- RESTAURANT AND TWO
WEEKS AGO AT MUCH. MY OWN STAFF
AND I WERE THE ONLY CUSTOMERS
OF THAT SMALL SANDWICH SHOP.
THE MOTHER AND HER DAUGHTER
TRYING TO HANG ON. THEY ARE NOT
UNIQUE THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO SO
FAR BUT THIS HELP IS VERY VERY
NECESSARY TO GIVE THEM HOPE AND
SOME SUSTENANCE. TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN. SENATOR MEN AND
SENATOR GROSSMAN SENATOR DOLLY.
RENDON SENATOR CASKEY SAID
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MANAGER FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I
APPLAUD THE HARD WORK THAT THE
GOVERNOR SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP HAVE PUT INTO THIS
MEASURE I WANT TO THANK YOU
BUDGETARY SKINNER- BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR CHAIR
CABALLERO AND TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF YOUR
EFFORTS. I'M PROUD AND HONORED
TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR OF SB
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD AS
DESCRIBED DIRECT ALMOST TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RELIEF TO STRUGGLING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS. WELL
WE CAN SEE A RETURN TO NORMALCY
JUST AROUND THE CORNER TOO MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING
TO STAY AFLOAT RIGHT NOW. YEAH
WE ALL KNOW THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO BE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WHICH MEANS
WE HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
HELP THEM GET THROUGH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED. A PANDEMIC
DRIVEN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT SB EIGHTY SEVEN
ALONG SIDE THE OTHER
SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY AID IN
THIS PACKAGE. OFFERED BY MADAME
PROTON ACTING SPEAKER RENDON
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. WILL PROVIDE
THE LIFELINE AT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED TO GET THROUGH
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS UNTIL OUR
ECONOMY FULLY REOPENS. I'M
GRATEFUL TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES
HERE FOR EMPHASIZING SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THIS BUDGET
PACKAGE. I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
CENTER NIELSEN AND RECOGNIZING
CENTER BOARD JUST FOR THE HARD
WORK HE'S PUT IN A SMALL
BUSINESS. RELIEF INCLUDING MANY
OF THE COMPONENTS OF THIS
PACKAGE. I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS ENTIRE PACKAGE
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT I
THINK THIS IS THE FISCALLY
PRUDENT THING TO DO. WE SHOULD
FOLLOW THE WINSTON AN EXAMPLE
SET BY JOSEPH IN THE BIBLE. BUT
WHEN FACED WITH A PERIOD OF
SEVEN YEARS A FEAST AND SEVEN
YEARS OF FAMINE- WISELY
COUNSELED. THAT WE SHOULD DRIVE
DOWN DURING THE FAMINE. NOW WE
ARE FACING THE WORST FAMINE IN
OUR LIFETIMES AND UNPRECEDENTED
PANDEMIC DRIVEN DOWNTURN. HI
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE TIME TO
BORROW AS LONG AS WE PAID BACK
WHEN TIMES ARE GOOD. I URGE YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT THIS PACKAGE
THANK YOU MA'AM. SHARE THANK
YOU SENATOR MEN SENATOR GROW.
AND THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SO I A TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IECE OF LEGISLATION AND
I'M REALLY EXCITED THAT WE'RE
USING THOSE ONE TIME FRIENDS
THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM THAT-
THE ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR THE
STATE AND THE GOVERNOR'S PUT
THIS THAT HE PUT HIM I BELIEVE
A MODEST PROPOSAL IN WITH
SENATOR PARTISAN SENATOR KABIRU
AT DOING ALL THE LEGWORK THEY
ACTUALLY CAME UP WITH AN
ADDITIONAL DOLLAR AMOUNT- I
APPLIED EVERYBODY WHO'S
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
THINK THAT TIME ALEXA MY
COMMENTS- ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
A BOTH MY COLLEAGUES. AT THAT
JUST PREVIOUSLY SPOKE THAT
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING AND
BUSINESSES ARE HURTING AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY-
HAVE A MECHANISM TO HELP THEM
GET THROUGH THE BALANCE OF THE
PANDEMIC I DO HAVE A QUESTION
BECAUSE WE DID TAKE UP- AB
EIGHTY JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO.
ARE THESE GRANTS CAN BE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME STACKS ISSUES OR
THE DEDUCTIONS THAT WE JUST S.
WENT THROUGH- WHAT'S THE
ANTICIPATION I GUESS OF THE
SAME- CRITERIA FOR TAX
DEDUCTIONS THAT WORK ON THE
FEDERAL P. PEOPLE LOAN PROGRAM
BECAUSE THIS IS BASICALLY A
STATE PPP LOAN PROGRAM RIGHT OR
A STATE PROGRAM THAT WILL
GRANDSON THE IN A BUSINESSES
WILL BE ABLE TO. ACCESS SO
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE PAY BACK
MEDS MECHANISM ARE THE
FORGIVABLE AND- IF NOT IS THERE
GONNA BE TAX DEDUCTIONS ARE
AVAILABILITY. FOR HOW'S THAT
GOING TO BE HANDLED. DEPARTMENT
OF FINE MORE ADDRESS THE- I'M
NOT SURE CAREFULLY IN A FINANCE
AND- THESE ARE SMALL BUSINESS
FRANCE THEY'RE NOT LOANS SO
THERE'S NO- NEED TO REPAY- THAT
IS THAT. THANKS THROUGH
TOPLINE- I'LL- I'LL ASK SOME
GEETA IF SHE HAS ANYTHING TO
ADD TO THAT. FOR THE TAX
PURPOSES CAN I DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE DAY TIMBERLAND. GOOD
MORNING YES SO- WHO ARE THESE
THESE GRANTS ARE NOT TAXABLE
THE OR NOT TAXES FOR CALIFORNIA
PURPOSES WE- WE DO NOT KNOW AND
CAN'T CONTROL WHAT WHETHER
THEIR TAXABLE FOR FEDERAL
GROUPS AS THEY THEY LIKELY ARE
BUT THAT IS OUT OF OUR HANDS
FOR MAKING THEM NONTAXABLE
FEDERAL GROUPS THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE OF A SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING NOW APPLIES FOR.
BLANK DOLLARS AND I'M IS THAT
LUCKY RECIPIENT OF GETTING THAT
GRANT THAT THERE WOULDN'T BE A
TAX LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH
IT SO I APPRECIATE YOU
EXPLAINING THAT. THANK YOU AND
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- AS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I'M BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE TO NOT HAVE TO. USE
THE CARES MONEY OR- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ABSORB THE COST FOR THE
P. PIECE FOR OUR BUSINESS BUT I
WOULD JUST SHARE WITH YOU
THERE'S MANY MANY BUSINESSES
OUT THERE THAT ARE. STRUGGLING
AND THEY ARE LIMPING ALONG I
GUESS THAT'S THE WORD THAT I
THINK. I HEAR FROM MOST MY
BUSINESSES ARE VERY FRUSTRATED
AND CHALLENGE SO I AM. VERY
PROUD TO BE PART OF THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I WANT TO
COMMEND THE- LEGISLATURE ON A
BIPARTISAN ROLE IT'S AMAZING
WHAT WE CAN DO. WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS THAT I THINK. WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AT SOME POINT WE
HAVE TO. FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
OUR ECONOMY BACK MOVING AT THE
END OF THE DAY. I MEAN. THIS IS
THIS IS THIS IS BORROWED I MEAN
YES SIR WE HAVE AN INFLUX OF
MONEY RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE'VE HAD THAT SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
BUDGET THAT WAS SHORT WE HAD.
WE'VE WE'VE EXTENDED PROP
THIRTY. AND YOU KNOW WHAT I
HEARD FROM. THE OTHER SENATOR
ABOUT YOU KNOW ON ABOUT JOSEPH
IN THE BIBLE WELL LET ME TELL
YOU WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN HAD
WE HAD RECORD TIMES AND WE HAVE
WE HAVE RECORD DEBT TO. ON TOP
OF THAT ON TOP OF THAT WE HAVE
RECORD. FEDERAL DEBT. AND
EVERYBODY SEEMS TO THINK THAT
ALL THIS GETS MORE MONEY FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE
JUST. EMAILING IT TO THE BANKS
IS NOT EVEN PRINTED MONEY AND
THINK ABOUT THE INFLATION. THEY
WERE GONNA HAVE IN THE FUTURE.
IS GOING TO BE ASTRONOMICAL
TWENTY. NINE TRILLION DOLLARS.
A TRILLION DOLLARS A THOUSAND
BILLIONS. OF BILLION IS A
THOUSAND MILLION IT'S REAL
MONEY IT'S MY DAUGHTER'S FUTURE
MY GRAND KIDS AND I DON'T EVEN
HAVE YET. HEY THESE BILLS BACK.
THE REAL OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE IS
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET OUR
PEOPLE BACK WORKING IN THEIR
BUSINESSES AND NOT HAVE TO
HELP. CONTINUE BAILOUT AND I DO
WANT TO JUST USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THE SAME
THING FOR OUR SCHOOLS MEDIA
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL IT'S MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S THOSE ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING TO THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC. WE
HAVE NOT EVEN SEEN YET
FINANCIALLY AND AN EMOTIONALLY
AND SOCIALLY SO I JUST THINK
THE- SENATORS AND- A FOR LOOP
ON A BIPARTISAN. BILL HERE BUT
WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
LONG TERM EFFECTS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU I THINK
SENATOR Y. CASKEY ROGER. OKAY I
RIGHTS HAVE MONEY JOIN AS
EVERYBODY REACHES THIS HAPPY
PLACE WITH THIS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS- THIS BILL I
REMEMBER WITH- AT THE EARLY ON
DECEMBER WHEN. SOME FIRST IDEA
WAS HATCHED THIRTY MINISTRATION
I THINK EVERYBODY CAN CLAIM
SOME BENEFIT ONE OF THE- ONE OF
THE IMPORTANT. ELEMENTS OF THIS
IS THAT SOME OF THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ACTUALLY CLOSE NOW BUT
THEY INTEND TO OPEN UP. ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FOR THE
SPONSORSAND LIKE SIXTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN. DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
VERY ACCESSIBLE ON THE ON THE
GO BIZ WEBSITE SO WHILE A LOT
OF US ARE LOOKING BACK IS THE
SCOPE AND STUFF AND ALL THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN SCOTTISH
CHOKING. THIS IS ALSO A FORWARD
LOOKING- MEASURE BECAUSE WITH
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
HAVE YOU GOT A BUSINESS OVER
MILLION THAT COULD BE. TWO
MONTHS WORTH OF PAYROLL FOR
MANY THESE FOR MANY THESE
BUSINESSES AND THAT'S- ANOTHER
MESSAGE THAT HAS TO GET UP
THERE BECAUSE THIS IS. THIS IS
THE STIPULATION. THAT WE HAVE
SEEN SOME OF THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE. ADMITTEDLY LIVE THAT IS
THAT THE CHECK FOR THEM TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET. THANK YOU.
FOR ANY OTHER I DON'T SEE OTHER
HANDS- SORRY SENATOR DRAWS HER
COLLEAGUES ARE SAYING LET'S GET
IT OUT GET IT OUT- A VERY
PRACTICAL QUESTION I'VE BEEN
ASKED IS WILL ALL OF THIS-
ASSISTANCE WHAT IS IT AVAILABLE
LIKE. NEXT WEEK BLOOM
EVERYTHING SET TO GO TO GET
THIS ASSISTANCE OUT WHETHER
IT'S A SMALL BUSINESS OR- ON
ANY OTHER PART OF THIS PACKAGE-
IF WE CAN GET THAT INFORMATION
THAT'S WHAT. PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO ASK IN BIG NUMBERS.
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT. YES I'LL
TRY NOT TO SEND YOU TO FOR A
RESPONSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
SO IN THE FIRST ROUND THAT
ENDED AT THE END OF THE YEAR-
TO THE APPLICATIONS- THE
SELECTED ON JANUARY SECOND. AND
THEY HAD- THEY GOT THEM I HAVE
FUNDS DISTRIBUTED OVER A FORTY
FIVE DAY PERIOD SO IN THE FIRST
ROUND- THEY GOT THEM ON A
ROLLING BASIS BY A CH
ELECTRONIC TRANSFER OVER A
FORTY FIVE DAY PERIOD AND I
ANTICIPATE THAT WOULD BE ABOUT
THE SAME TIME PERIOD. FOR
SUBSEQUENT ROUNDS AS WELL. BUT
WE TRY TO GET THOSE- FUNDS-
I'LL AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. GREAT
SERVICE I THINK WE ARE NOW
READY. TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON THIS ENTIRE PACKAGE- WHICH
HAVE AS HAS BEEN NOTED BY
MEMBERS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BY MYSELF IS QUITE. AN
IMPRESSIVE IN NEEDED FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR OUR UNIVERSITIES
FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR
OUR STUDENTS FOR A CHILD CARE
WORKERS AND SO MANY MORE. IT'S
A VERY VERY GOOD AN IMPORTANT
PACKAGE SEVEN NOW TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. WILL FIRST SEE
WHETHER WE HAVE- ANYONE IN OUR
OVERFLOW HEARING ROOMS AND
WHILE WE'RE CHECKING ON THAT
pCALL IN NUMBER IS. K. WHERE'S
THAT POLAND NUMBER- THE CALL IN
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT
SIX ONE ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE AND
I WILL BE ASKING- PUBLIC
COMMENT TO KEEP THEIR REMARKS
TO ONE MINUTE WHICH- DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN THE CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- WE ARE THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRS ALLOWED TO INSTITUTE
SUCH TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
ON SHOW AGAIN LET ME JUST CHECK
IF THERE'S ANY IN OUR HERE THE
REMOTE HEARING ROOM IT DOES NOT
LOOK LIKE THAT IS THE CASE SO
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FOR A KINDERGARTEN TELL ME
WHEN- WHAT THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY TWO
WAITING FOR COMMENT. ALL RIGHT-
GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE LINES.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
RESPONSES- WITH WHAT YOU'RE
GOING ALONG PARTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE V. EIGHTY THREE AT AB
EIGHTY EIGHT ARE WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WORKING TOGETHER
OPPOSITION DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OFFERING THE POVERTY I REALLY
WASN'T THE EXTENT OF THE
OFFSHORE ON CAPTURED PEOPLE
WORK ALL PEOPLE PARTY MORE
SPECIFICALLY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS. WHO DID NOT HAVE
AN ITEM NUMBER WILL BE HIT THE
HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE
RESOURCES OF THE STATE TO
ENSURE ALL PEOPLE ABLE TO THE
APP OF THE WEEK. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. I HAD
MY- YOU CAN JUST KEEP GOING.
THANK YOU RIGHT TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LUCIANA I'M WITH IN A SEVEN
ACT FROM CAN'T BE AND THE
CALIFORNIA- FOR A THANK. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT AND THEN LAID.
FOR THE ANSWER IF I. AND I'M-
THAT IS BEST FOR STEP TOWARD
FINALLY RESTORING. BE CUT- K.
AS RECIPIENTS ON THE UNDER THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LAW. WICKS
THAT'S MEAN MUCH FOR ADDRESSES-
AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR THE ESTEEM OF THE TO IN.
THE EIGHTEEN COMMUNITY RIGHT
THAT PRIORE CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF I HOPE. THAT YOU.
YOU KNOW HELP IS- WITH THEM
POLICY COME INCOMING THANK.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LED THE SANTOS ON
BEHALF OF THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT TODAY
FOR THE IMMEDIATE RELIEF
PACKAGE YOU WILL BE PROVIDING
TEN MILLION PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO ARE IN WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE HIGHER AND
CALFRESH OUTREACH AND
INVOLVEMENT ADNAN FUNDING HOW
WORKS THE WHITE INCOME
DISREGARD EITC OUTREACH AND THE
CHILD CARE AND KNOW YOU. AND
WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND PARTICULAR
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS ALTHOUGH WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT PAID SICK
LEAVE WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
EARLY ACT PACKAGE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
NOT TO ENSURE RELIEF PROVIDED
TO ALL. WORKING CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU. THANK LINE FOR THREE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW WANT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON
BEHALF OF OUR ESSENTIAL CORE
WORKERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SHAPE SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE TO LEARN THE HOUSING FOR
HARNESS PROGRAM PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO HELP
FARMWORKERS QUARANTINE DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND SUPPORT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROVIDING
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO OUR LOW
INCOME RURAL FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME I
MARTY ON MURDER MY FAMILY
MEMBER- TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AN
ADVOCATE FEEDING CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK JUST ONE
EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE ENTIRE ECONOMIC UP PACKAGES
BASICALLY THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR- PAYMENTS IN GRANT-
ESPECIALLY TO THE GRANT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR AT
THE SCIENCE IS BEING CAPTURED
THE PROGRAM FOR THE-
IMMIGRANTS. AND CAL WORKED OUT
GOING TO REALLY HELP PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES INCLUDING
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS AND
ALSO EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHTY SEVEN THAT WOULD
HELP I BELIEVE- ELIGIBLE
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND-
PROVIDERS WHO ARE NONPROFIT TO
SERVE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES-
AND THINGS- I GUESS ONE ALSO
THANK. ALL OF YOU IN THE ROOM
THERE OKAY WE'RE ALL GOING TO
STRESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
MAKING GOVERNMENT WORK. FOR ALL
OF US THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER NUMBER. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS NOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOMEOWNER WHO CANNOT OCCUR
DURING THE CENTER WERE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE DREAM PLAN
DOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA WORKERS WHEN I CAN
BUT IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE NEED
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO ALL MORE
YOU NEEDED TO PROTECT THOUSANDS
OF UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS LAST
HOUSE YOU MIGHT THINK I THINK
TAXES AND INCLUDE ALL CLIPBOARD
OR UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS.
PLEASE CONSIDER INVESTING IN
HOW REGIONAL AT EVERY MORNING
AND WITHOUT THAT IS ABLE TO
SIGN UP FOR AND I THINK I WOULD
AS MUCH NEEDED EIGHT- I THINK
HE HAD BORROWED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBER- THIS IS JEANNIE SAID
FOR THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS- CAPRICA MORE
AND FOR AND WE IN HELP AND HAD
WORKED ON. FORTY YEARS TO
PRESERVE SCALE IN PRINT
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
CAP STRONGLY SUPPORT SB EIGHTY
SEVEN CONDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROGRAM TOP OF THE
SUBCONTRACTOR OUTREACH PARTNER
HAS HELPED THOUSANDS OF OUR
MEMBERS APPLY FOR THE FIRST TWO
ROUNDS OF THE PROGRAM. AND THE
PROGRAM CONTINUES WE CONTINUE
TO URGE THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SPANISH LANGUAGE APPLICATION TO
ENSURE THAT THE FARMERS WE WORK
WITH WHO SPEAKER RIGHT
PRIMARILY IN SPANISH YOU'RE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY APPLY A
CAP STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
HOUSING FOR THE HARDEST FUNDING
TO SUPPORT OUR FARMWORKERS.
THEY WANT TO FLAG THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES
FOR EARLY ACTION THREE POINT
THREE FIVE MILLION FOR URGENTLY
NEEDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
HELP SMALL MIDSIZE AND
UNDERSERVED FARMERS
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE THE MARAT
OF THE FEDERAL CODE RELIEF
PROGRAMS THIS RELATIVELY SMALL
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE COULD
HELP LEVERAGE MANY MORE TIMES
WITH MANY DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
RELIEF. AND WE HOPE TO SEE THIS
CRITICAL INITIATIVE ADVANCE
QUICKLINK YOU ANYTHING GIVEN
YOUR ON THE. SHIP DURING THAT
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FOUR CALL. MORE MADAM THANK
YOU- FOR READING MY A PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY ON SOMETHING
SHOPPING CALIFORNIA. OF FOOD
BANKS CALLING FOR SUPPORT AB
EIGHTY EIGHT HI- THE THANK YOU
IN THE LEGISLATURE VERY MUCH
FOR THE FSI INCLUSION- AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING TO
RESTORE THE CUTS FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION FOR THE LAST. TEN
YEARS- SOCIETY RECIPIENTS ARE
VERY MUCH- SUFFERING THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND WE HOPE THAT
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST STEP.
TOWARD FINALLY RESTORING ACCESS.
WE ALSO OFFER THE STIMULUS
SHOULD BE MORE. OF THE I.
TWENTY- THERE ARE MANY THAT
THAT- ONLY TAKES IN YELLOW IF
NOT GOING TO COVER WHAT
PROTECT- INLAND. I KNOW THERE
WAS A COMMON EARLIER ABOUT HOW.
PHOTO WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION
AND THEIR FUTURE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN IF YOU COULD WRAP
UP FOR NOW AND HOW. BUT HOPE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE FUTURE CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FRANK
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
OF THE NUMBER IS THAT THE LOCAL
GUY YELLING REALLY LIKE THEY
LOOK LIKE THAT ARE DEFINITELY
THAT PRODUCT I'M NOT I'M HEROES
THAT I BIGELOW EVERY NO ON
YELLING LET TO HAVE AN EXCEL A
COLLEAGUE. FOR ABOUT IS A
PRETTY MAN BACK DOWN TO FIVE IN
A ABOUT THE DID BUT AFTER
MEDIAN DEL BACK ON LOW MEANT
THAT. BILL IS A AND I'M IN
THERE IT WILL BE TO BE A-
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM THE PROBLEM
IS THAT. I'D BE LEFT OUT THING
IN THE LEAD UP THE BUDGET IS
THE MORE. ORACLE YOU. IS THAT
PEOPLE THE NEW. BILLION.
CARESSES THANK YOU VERY SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MEDICARE NUMBERS KATHY FROM THE
LIITADO FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THERE IS
SO MUCH TO SUPPORT OF THE
PACKAGE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY FAIR AND PARTICULAR I
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB
EIGHTY FIVE AND EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS INCLUDING THE
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS ARE
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
REPEATING CAL WORK AFTER
FINANCES AND HAPPY AS WELL AS
THE DECISION TO INCLUDE. AYE
COMPILERS IN THE- THANK YOU
ALSO FOR PROVIDING HER YOUR FUN
TO NAME COUNTY. WHAT COULD BE
HOME OF COLLEGE. IN THE
CALFRESH AS WELL AS FOR ME I
REACH FOR THIS GROUP. AND
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE YOU
ENSURING THOSE RECEIVING
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT INCREASES
ARE NOT PENALIZED WITH APPLYING
FOR CAL WORK. OVERALL THIS
PACKAGE FOR RECOGNITION GET
SUPPORT FOR THOSE STRUGGLING IN
THE PANDEMIC WE THANK YOU FOR
THINKING OF THEM AND
PRIORITIZING THEM. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING OUT
WHICH I FORGOT TO THE-
EXPANSION OF CALPERS. FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
WATER NEXT. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CINDY HILLARY AND I
AM CALLING REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIAMEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE WANT TO- WEIGH IN IN
SUPPORT ON EIGHTY EIGHTY THAT
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
LOAN- TAX CONFORMITY BILL-
WHILE WE SEE THIS AS A HUGE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
ENSURING THAT WE CAN KEEP OUR
PRACTICE DOORS OPEN. AND ACCESS
TO CARE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WEEK YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT IT IS ONLY A FAST AND BACK
WITH. MOST OF OUR 87% OF OUR
PRACTICES STILL REPORTING
CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR PHYSICAL
HEALTH WE WANT TO MAKE THE
POINT THAT THIS IS ONE FACTOR
NOT THE FINAL STEP THAT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN TO ENSURE PRACTICE
BY ABILITY AND ACCESS TO KAREN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE QUICK ACTION ON
THE ISSUE. AND THE THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF ITS NEED
PRIOR TO- TAX FILING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU I FORTY ONE GO OUT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THIS IS A LIFE THE
WILD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUM WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INCLUSION OF FIFTY MILLION AND
RELIEF FUNDING FOR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS IN SB EIGHTY SEVEN
AS YOU KNOW WITH THE MAJORITY
OF THE STATE'S COUNTIES IN THE
PURPLE PEER MUSEUMS ARE STILL
PROHIBITED TO BE OPEN INDOORS
IN ANY CAPACITY WHILE SHOPPING
MALLS AND RETAIL ARE OPEN.
CALIFORNIA'S MUSEUM THEY'RE
GOING ON A YEAR OF NEAR TOTAL
SHUTDOWN LOSING AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS A
DAY SINCE LAST MARCH THANK YOU
FOR INCREASING THE ALLOCATION
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FROM TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO
FIFTEEN MILLION. AND ALLOWING
NONPROFIT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
OF ALL SIZES TO APPLY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A PROGRAM THAT
OPTIMIZES EASE OF APPLICATION
AND ADMINISTRATION AND PROVIDE.
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS THAT ONLY COMES OUT
ON WITH THE WHITE HOUSE WHAT
THE RESOURCE CENTER AND ALSO
WITH THE SAFETY NET FOR OUR
CORE MISSION WE'RE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE RELIEF THAT
THE PACKAGE THAT THE GOLDEN
STATE THE MINUTE PACKAGE IS
GOING TO BRING OUR COMMUNITY
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT DOES NOT
GO FAR ENOUGH. TO REACH ALL OF
OUR UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
OUGHT WE ALSO BEING THAT- IN
ORDER FOR THIS RELIEF TO BECOME
AVAILABLE THE STATE MUST MAKE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN OUR
REGIONAL THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
WITHOUT THAT IF PEOPLE TO SIGN
UP FOR AN IBM. GOLDEN STATE IS
ONLY IF EVERY CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS THERE I ALSO JUST. WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. TO MAKE ME
CRY HEARING ACCESSIBLE TO. BUT
WHAT THE WHAT THAT YOU GUYS.
DISCONNECTED IS A MODEL SPANISH
SPEAKERS AND IT IS NOT ALL
CHANGE THAT THERE IS NO IS YOUR-
OF IT STAGE IN THE GAME. ONE
AGAIN WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR EVERY THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
LOCKED ALLEGED. SOME OF YOUR
DATE OF GONE ABOVE IN THE AND
CHEN PARK. EIGHT EDUCATE OUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
RIGHT FORTY SIX GO OUT. HELLO
MY IS ANA HOW PROVIDED AT IT
WILL A TELL AND A MEMBER OF
CARRYING ADVOCATE COLLEGE- WE
COMMEND THE LEGISLATURE ONGOING
KILLER DEAL RECOGNIZING THAT
THAT WAS DONE BY MEMBERS AND
STAFF TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
OUR COALITION RECOMMENDED THE
KELLY AGENCY TAX STRUCTURE IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO REACH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS ACCORDING
CALIFORNIANS. ESPECIALLY IF I
CAN BUY THEIR NON CLEARED OUT
OF LAST YEAR TO THE CARRIER B.
WHAT THE HELL THAT COALITION IS
PLEASED TO SEE THE PROGRESS
MADE IN THE GOLDEN STATE SENATE
DEAL IT DOES RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT EQUITY FOR THE HARDSHIP
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR ITEM BUYERS
OF HIM 70% HAVE CHILD
ATTENDANCE ENERGY NO BETTER-
AGES. WE ARE FIRMLY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY EIGHT AND OTHER
EFFORTS TO MEET THE CRITICAL
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS EXCLUDED
FROM FEDERAL RELIEF AND OTHER
PUBLIC SERVICES SUCH AS POWER.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
GREATER FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES THE TARGETED
INVESTMENT COMPARE AND CHILD IF
I TO HELP HIM. LASTLY WE WOULD
POINT OUT A CRITICAL NEED TO
SUPPORT TAX PREPARATION
ASSISTANCE ALL FILERS BUT
ESPECIALLY THOSE WILL NOW BE
ELIGIBLE BUT CONSTRUCTING WE
URGE FOR LET TO TAKE ACTION TO
SUPPORT THE FINAL. AT THE EARLY
OPPORTUNITY THANK. YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS AS SUCH AS AND I
CALL FOR A COUPLE COMMENT ON
BEHALF OF ANDERSON FROM
RESEARCH CENTER LAW ANGELES. WE
APPRECIATE IT KNOWLEDGE IS
LARGEST LEADERS AND GOV NEWS
AND GOVERNOR NEW SOME BEING A
TO INCLUDE EXAMPLE THERE'S
ANOTHER SIMILAR ON THE FIRST.
DEMOCRATS OUR COMMUNITY AND-
FAMILIES IN THE- FALLOUT HAVE
DEFINITELY A GLOBAL ECONOMY.
AFFECTING THE MOST. UNDER
RESEARCH POPULOUS. THAT IT WE
CAN START OUR OWN FUNDS BE ABLE
TO. THEM MONEY THE STATE
IMMIGRANT FAMILY AS WELL PARTS
OF THE- IT THINK. DISASTER
RELIEF WITH THE- FOR IMMIGRANTS
FIND AND SELLING BUT- RELY. AND
LEARNING THAT ARE COMING
MEMBERS PRIMARILY NEED MY-
BURKE WHO AND HOUSING- TO BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE. IF YOU MADE IT
TOUGH FOR THAT TELL. HAVE BEEN
DURING TWENTY FOUR IS NEXT. AND
ONGOING. ENGINE TO BE EFFECTIVE
AND INCLUSIVE RELIEF ALL. AND
WORK ACROSS CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THIRTY ONE PLEASED
AHEAD. BY THREE ONE PLEASE GO
OUT. WELL RIGHT AWAY FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLINDSIDED
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
AWAY SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME THESE ORDERS ARE
GONE. I'M CALLING ON THE
TROUBLED BY EMPLOYEES HERE-
CALIFORNIA AND I'M NOT
ADVOCATING THANK GOD- THE
RECORDING IS. I MEAN. BECAUSE
MANY OF FUNDING PRETENDED
LOOKING UP ON HE EAST OF THE
NOTHING BY THERE. MUSIC AND NOW
WE EVEN AFFORD TO CREATE RAIN
AT THIS TIME. SO WILL REALLY BE
ENCOURAGING TO PROSTHESES
CORNER STEAMERS BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO HELP MANY FAMILY NEEDS
THE NIGHT ENDED UP BEING ON A
TEMA COMMUNITY. AND- ANYTHING
DELAYED JUST FOR TAX ALONG AND
BE CAREFREE NOT ONLY GOING TO
HELP. BECAUSE BACK HOLD FUNDING
WHICH IS- WE ACTUALLY CAN'T
AFFORD CHILD CARE AND SOMETIMES
POLITICALLY RELYING ON AND.
EIGHTEEN HE ALSO SO AB ONE
DOWNTURN J. AND I SCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY NEED WHEN YOU'RE
AND CLEAN UP PRETTY STAY
KEEPING MY DOWN ANYTHING.
INTERCONNECTING ARE ENOUGH ME
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
I'M FIFTY THREE CALL. HE DIDN'T
THIS IS NANCY ALLBRITTON JUSHIN
SERVICE IN MOTION. AND SINCE
SEVEN OF MY CALL HAD SHOULD
HAVE MADE THE ALREADY I WILL BE
VERY BRIEF AND SAY A HEART OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRESSA CYCLE AND
ADDRESS. HERS ON THE
INDIVIDUALS IN MOTION. WE FULLY
SUPPORT THESE AT HER TO SPEND
THE GO GATE STIMULUS SIXTY ON
WE ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL THE
LEDGE SO ON THE- AND WE HOPE
YOU LOOK FINE WAYS TO I AM
FIBERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
FORTY. ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS MARIA STORY I
WOULD BE WAIT CONSISTS GO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE GOLDEN IN
THIS PACKAGE LATER AND
LEGISLATURE DIESEL BENNETT
FAMILIES NEED IT THE MOST AND
CAL IT WORKS I. AND ESPECIALLY
INCLUDE BILL SHOULD I. I'VE
BEEN LONGER SANDWICH CHAIN MAY
ALREADY MOTHER ON AS I AM WHEN
MY CHILDREN YOUNGER THEY WERE
ALL IN CASE- FOR MY MOM IT
MEANS THAT SHE EXTRA MONEY TO
BUY MEADOW THAT'S NOT COVERED.
AND ALSO. JUST TO. B. MARK
COMES. BY MUSIC BY- NEW
CLOTHING BECAUSE SHE IS- NOT AN
OLDER PERSON AND SHE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY INCOME OTHER THAN
FINANCES I AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD- I'M GLAD
THAT WE ARE DOING THIS- DIESEL
HELP CREATE EQUITY SO NOBODY IS
LEFT BEHIND. AND I HOPE IT
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOSH THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I
WANT TO CHANGE I THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
CARING TODAY AND ALL THE HELP
OF PROVIDING TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS- I PERSONALLY WANT
TO SUPPORT AND THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR FFI INCLUSION
I'M ALSO SPEAKING TO THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR AT THAT BY AND
THE CALLIE I T. C. COALITION-
DAY AT THE DIET THAT THE GRANT
HAVE NEVER RECOVERED FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION AND THIS IS A
GREAT. FIRST STEP AND AS OTHERS
HAVE STATED WE ALSO ADD SUPPORT
AND BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE MORE INCLUSION OF ITN FILERS.
THANK YOU BYE BYE. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS A MUNICIPALITY
ABOUT OWNERS BECOME HAPPENED
JOB THAT JUSTICE SAN FRANCISCO-
COLLECTION COMMUNITY KERR
ORGANIZATIONS THE MEMBER
SIXTEEN FOR ALL COLLEGE
COALITION AND EQUANIMITY OF
ARTISTS THAT I ONE OF THE STEPS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY
TAKEN IMPROVING GOLDEN STATE
AND LET. BUT WILL INCLUDE THE
MUCH CAN ASSISTANCE THAT MANY
OF THOSE NON DOCUMENTS
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH FOR ALMOST A
YEAR NOW NO ONE EARLIER STEPS
TO MAKE THE FINAL STEP IN
ENSURING THAT EVERY
UNDOCUMENTED WORKER AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE COVERED BY THIS
RELIEF PACKAGE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THOUSANDS ARE LEFT OUT
THOUSANDS OUT WILL BE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR FAMILIES HEADS DURING A
PANDEMIC. STRUGGLING TO FIVE
BETWEEN RISKING THE HEALTH OF
MY INCOME ARE JUST GO HUNGRY-
WE CAN'T HAVE AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THAT HOLDING SOME OF
THAT WE MUST EXPAND I CAN
ACCESS AND INVESTING IN OUT
REACHED INCLUDE ON DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE NEED A
BOLD STATEMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT THE STATE CAN
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GIVE ME A LOT I THINK LAW
BARBECUE THAT FROM THE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS SUCCESS. THE
HIGHER EDUCATION RESEARCH
POLICY ADVOCATE ORDER. IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROVISION AND
EIGHT FIVE DIFFERENT ONCE
MILLION EARLY ACTION EMERGING
THING IN AID. FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHAT THE REMOVE OF THE
PREVIOUS THE CAN ALLAH
LIMITATION. RELATED TO FOR OF
ALONG OR- WHICH WOULD AFFECT
MANY STRUGGLING WITH THE ON.
COSTS AND BASICALLY. INSURING
YOU CRITICAL REPORTS CAN BE THE
SMOOTHLY AND EFFICIENTLY AS SHE
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM STUDENTS
TO. OR RUN AN ALL SHOULD HAVE
THEIR PAY NEEDS. THAT THEY CAN
BE. ON THE BOTTOM THEY WANT
ATTEND FOR THE TRAINING BE ON
THE TO DO SO FOR. OF THREE
INCLUDING WORKS FAMILY OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES IT'S ONLY BEEN
MAGNIFIED BY THE PANDEMIC
ADDITIONALLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED
BY EINEN UNDEREMPLOYMENT DURING
THE ONGOING CRISIS. TO REALIZE
EMERGENCY AID FULL POTENTIAL
ACCORDING STUDENT HIGHER
EDUCATION EXACTLY TRONG
REPORTED EARLY ACTION ABOUT.
WHICH REPEAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S. MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. THANK YOU
I'M SURE NINE IS GOING. THANK
YOU TEARS AND MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EXPANDING
EMERGENCY PAYCHECK LEAVE TO
WORKERS THE EXPLORATION OF BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL LEAVE ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF LAST
YEAR WORKERS HAVE OFTEN FOUND
THEMSELVES WITH EITHER
INADEQUATE OR NO ACCESS TO SICK
LEAVE. LEAVING THEM WITH REALLY
NO OPTION OTHER THAN TO GO TO
WORK WHILE SICK SPREAD THE
VIRUS TO THEIR COWORKERS INTO
THE PUBLIC OR TO FOREGO WAGES
AND- OTHER WHICH IS A GOOD
OPTION BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE
THAT ARE FORCED TO WORK WHILE
SICK THAT IS REALLY NOT WHAT WE
WANT WHEN TRYING TO. REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF PEOPLE GETTING
THE DISEASE AND STOP THE SPREAD
OF THE DISEASE SO FOR ALL RIGHT
REASONS WE THINK IT SHOULD BE A
HUGE PRIORITY AND SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE INCLUDED IN THE
EARLY ACTION BUDGET TO EXTEND
EMERGENCY. PAYCHECK WORKERS.
THANK YOU. THANK I'M SEVENTY
TWO GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BOB
THOUSAND MY THEY CAL IMMIGRANT
HOW THAT AND I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRED INTERNAL FOR THEIR
EFFORTS AROUND THE GOLDEN
DANIEL AND- WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE GOLDEN GATE
DANNIELYNN AND REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE- I CAN
FINALLY BEGIN EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL RELIEF. HOWEVER I JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT THIS DOESN'T
COVER ALL OF THE RELIEF THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
AND WE ARE CREATING AY QUALITY
AS A RESULT- FOR EXAMPLE A
HOUSEHOLD WITH YOU I CAN BY
THEIR PARENTS AND TWO CHILDREN
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR A MAXIMUM
OF TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
GOLDEN GATE STIMULANTS RELIEF
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL. BUT THAT
ONLY ACCOUNT 421% OF THE
FEDERAL RELIEF THAT THEY'VE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE EFFORTS AND SUPPORT
THE GOLDEN GATE STIMULUS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
ACHIEVED FULL EQUITY FOR OUR
IMMIGRANT. COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU I
SEVENTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE SKINNER MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS A STRATEGY THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED PLUS- INDEPENDENT
LIVE MUSIC VENUES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WELL
YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS OUT RELIEF EFFORTS IN
SB EIGHTY SEVEN- INDEPENDENT
MUSIC VENUES WERE THE FIRST TO
CLOSE AND WILL BE THE LAST TO
REOPEN. THE VENUES ARE LESS
THAN ONE MONTH AWAY FROM A FULL
YEAR OF NINETY PLUS PERCENT
REVENUE LOSS- THE BILL WITH IT-
CAP AT TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
IN REVENUE AND GRANTS CAPPED AT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND LEAVE A
MAJORITY OF THE INDEPENDENT
MUSIC VENUES WHICH ARE THE
CORNERSTONE OF MANY
COMMUNITIES- ECONOMIC- DEBT OR
ENTERTAINMENT- A. CONDOM USE.
THE NEW YORK VENUES ARE OUT OF
CALL CALL- WITH THE GRANT BY
THE WEALTHY. PUT THE SMALL DENT
IN DATA MANY OF VENUES BEEN
ROCK OUT- FORWARD TO WITH- WE
YOU MADAM CHAIR WITH THE MAN.
TO FURTHER INTO THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS- GOES. IN THE BE ABLE
TO SAVE OUR- BUT APPRECIATE THE
ABOUT THAT THE NEWS. PLAN AND
WHAT THE LARGEST. INQUIRE KID
WHO'S BUSINESS AND WE TO WORK
YOU TO SAVE US HERE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO NOTE-
THE- THIS- STIMULUS THE
CULTURAL. I SET ASIDE HAS.
LIFTED THAT- REVENUE CAP. AND
ALSO ALLOWS FOR A LARGER GRANT
SO IT IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
LAST- THE ROUND OF SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS THAT JUST WENT
OUT. SO JUST- YOU CAN LOOK AT
THE DETAILS IN THE BILL IN
PRINT. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
FOUND. IN VENUES OF THAT STORY
YOU'LL SEE THERE ARE SOME NEW
CRITERIA. IN A MODERATOR FIVE.
YOU CAN KEEP GOING I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO QUEUE UP IN A
MOMENT WHO ELSE'S OF WAITING
BUT IN THE NEXT SET OF FOLKS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ANOTHER BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE THAT NEEDS TO
FOLLOW THIS I'M GOING TO ASK
PEOPLE NOW IF YOU COULD LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THIRTY
SECONDS. SO THAT WE CAN GET ALL
THE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT STILL
LEAVE ENOUGH TIME FOR THE
SECOND BUDGET SUB. SO COLORS
COULD YOU NOW- IT THIRTY
SECONDS YOU REALLY APPRECIATE
IT RIGHT MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ANDREA FERNANDES I'M WITH BUT
THEM AND GO INTO THANK YOU- THE
MOBILE WHAT YOU ALL DO IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOLDEN STATE
ADMINISTRA BROWNIES THEY REALLY
NEED AND NOW IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS NOT OVER AND FAMILY
AND UNDOCUMENTED BY MAYBE. A
STRONG. GAIN IN THE TIME OF
MEET. IN RIPARIAN RARE CLOSING.
AND OTHER AYE WE NEED PAY AND I
WANTED TO STAY YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HELLO MY
NAME IS WILLIE MARQUEZ I'M A
MEMBER OF VOICES SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M AWFUL AT THE PRESIDENT
SOMETHING TO PUT ADVOCACY IN
HELPING BEYOND DOCUMENTED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I'M
CALLING TO PUT THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER. FOR CAL WORKS AT THE
SIGN CAN CALMLY WITH THAT
URGENTLY NEED HELP. ALTHOUGH
THIS HUNDRED WILL ELP PAY FOR
PP COMPLIANCE RANKS. UTILITIES
AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS THAT
FAMILIES LIKE MYSELF WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN NEED- DURING THE HARSH
EFFECTS THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE TIME AND ALLOWING ME TO
COMMENT. I THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY LOOK BETTER THAN A
LITTLE SECOND BETTER. BY
DEMOCRATIC- HELLO MICHAEL. FOR
WELL LOTUS ONE OF DAY WELCOME
PLACE LITTLE STOP ON INSIDE YOU
HAVE BEEN WANT TO HAVE A POWER.
WE SAID I AM GOING TO. NOW I
THINK OKAY I DON'T USE
COMPUTERS OKAY ONE LAST. I
DON'T. THANK YOU RIGHT THREE
THREE IS GOING. RIGHT EIGHT TO
REACH GO AHEAD. RIGHT EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JUSTIN ROW THAT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE WORKER OWN
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA COALITION
THANKS TO SENATORS CABALLERO
AND MEN FOR SB EIGHTY SEVEN AND
DIDN'T SEE ANY CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE AROUND WORKER OWNED
BUSINESSES AND THEY'RE SO WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
PARTNERSHIP IN THE LEGISLATURE.
TO ENSURE THAT THESE OTHERWISE
QUALIFYING BUSINESSES THAT ARE
AND DO THE BURDEN IN ACCESSING
THE ADDITIONAL TWO POINT ONE
BILLION IN THE COVERAGE RELIEF
GRANT MONEY- WE HAVE CLOSE TO
NINE HUNDRED WORKER OWNED
BUSINESSES EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE. URBAN AND RURAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK BY EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE SKINNER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS WE
ARE AN APPLICATION PARTNER IN
THE CURRENT RELIEF PROGRAM AND
HAVE HELPED THOUSANDS OF
NONPROFITS NAVIGATE THIS
APPLICATION PROCESS WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT NONPROFITS ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS PROGRAM AND
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT SB
EIGHTY SEVEN PROPOSES. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE BILL
REQUIRES NONPROFIT EXPERTISE
FOR OUTREACH AND OTHER
NONPROFIT TIME. PHONONS WEEK TO
REMAIN CALM THAT THE APPLE
PROCESS ITSELF SERVING AS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
NONPROFITS WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM APPLICATION
REFLECTS THE STRUCTURE.
FINANCES NEED THE CONTRIBUTION
OF THE SECTOR. THANK YOU TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR STAFF AND
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR WHICH- THANK
YOU. YOU'RE RIGHT NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
REPORT OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS IN THE SMALL BUSINESS
GRANTS AND WE THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK IN ACCOMPLISHING
IN MAKING THISAN EARLY ACTION-
BUDGET DEAL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M COMMITTEE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE AMONG
THE WORLD'S LINERS AND I DO
VOLUNTEER WORK WITH HUNGER
ACTION LA AND THE NORTH
HOLLYWOOD AND CAN'T WAIT TO
TANGERINE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART
FOR. FOR THE GOLDEN STIMULATE
THAT INCLUDES DESPERATE BY
RECIPIENT AND HOPEFULLY THAT
SOME BUT SOME POINT IN TIME
WE'LL BE ABLE TO INCREASE THE
STATE PORTION OF SSI. AT SIGHT
PAYMENT BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
RECOVERED FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION I WOULD ALSO LIKE-
YOU WOULD DRAFT FOOD YOU NEED.
FOR PEOPLE. BRANCH OF
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO SUPPORT NOT.
NON. DATE THE ART. WELL TO HELP
THE ART AND ALSO WE ON WORK TO
SO I THANK YOU FOR THE BOTTOM
MY THANK. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WANT THREE GO AHEAD. THIS GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
THAT EAGLE WITH OR HOW WORKERS
RESOURCE FOR. AND THIS NET FOR
ALL- I MEAN SOME OF AB AT A- WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE REAL THEY
BRING TO OUR MARKET CALLUM
WORKER WITH LIKE. CRITICALLY
NEED REALLY TO AVAILABLE TO ALL
THE STOPS SHORT OF FULLY
DELIVERING THE RELIEF TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE YET TO
RECOVER FROM THIS ONGOING
ENDEMIC. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MIGHT WANNA ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE WINNER. WHEN OF THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED BACK IF IT
IF IT WILL BE A PART OF THOSE.
ARE ON THE. OKAY BUT NOT ALL
THESE FARM AND TALK SO.
XPLOCIAL MORTAL BEING ON HERE
CAMPUS OPEN AN IRA A FAN OF
MILLION YOU KNOW ABLE. HE SAID
ALMOST CURRENT FUNDING. INTO
UNLESS. HIM NUMBER I MONDAY
BILLED TO CAN THAT THERE'S A TO
FIND LOOKING THE NAME OF THE
DOCTOR IT LOOKS OF THE RIVER
WHAT TIME HONOR NOT ANYMORE-
AND I THINK WE'LL BE BACK IN.
THAT ECONOMY CLASS HOLDEN MORE
THAN AT THE IN. ARE YOU FROM.
YOU HAVE THAT CHECKED THE OTHER
PHONE LINES SO WE'VE GOT ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. ALL RIGHT.
THEN IF WE HAVE- HEARD ALL OF
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT ON LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS BEFORE I
START ASKING FOR MOTIONS. ALL
RIGHT THE SENATOR MELINDA IS
DID YOU HAVE YOUR HAND UP NO
OKAY SO- THEN LET ME- TAKE A
MOTION. WITH THE FIRST ONE
WE'RE GOING TO DO- POLICIES CAN
APPLY BILL LIST. A LOT OF
THINGS IN FRONT OF US HERE- LET
ME ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB
EIGHTY FIVE THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. CENTER PAN. S. SO MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN'S ON THE SECOND
FLOOR K. STORY WEAKENED- HAVE A
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
NOW CABALLERO CABALLERO I FOR
DAISY ORTEGA HI DOLLY. DALY NO
THE RAZA. TORONTO HI EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. LAYERED
LEHRER HI MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ SENATOR MELENDEZ NOW
MELENDEZ AND NOW. MAN MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI THE CHAU ABOVE.
PAN THEN I'LL ROTH. HI STERN.
WHY CAL SKI. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT- ROLE OPEN FOR- ABSENT
MEMBERS AND ALLOW ME NOW TO
TAKE A MOTION ON AB AT T. TAX
CONFORMITY PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM. SENATOR A PAN MOVED GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE A MOTION ROLL
CALL PLEASE. AB AT THE MOTION
TO PASS CENTER SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. CABALLERO.
ZERO FIVE CORTESE CORTESE HI
ALI. DAWALY II THE RAZA.
TORONTO I EGGMAN. EGGMAN ONLINE
GROWTH. GROW BY BLARED. BLARED
I'D MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MIN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
ARTICLE JOE BLOW. THE TROUBLE
ON. NIELSEN NOTIFIED DID YOU
HEAR THAT. OKAY NIELSEN NOTE
I'D- PAN IN HI ROTH ROTH FIVE
STERN WHAT KASKY. WE WILL ALSO
LEAVE THAT OPEN NO ACTUALLY WE
I THINK WE CAPTURED ALL MEMBERS
AND THAT. NO WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN OKAY- ALLOW ME TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB.
EIGHTY TO. CERVANTES EXCELLENT
QUICK WITH THE HAND GO AHEAD
SENATOR PAN. YOU MADE ITS-
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN. PUT AB
WHICH AB AB AB ONE- I THOUGHT
I'D GET YES SORRY POLICIES AB
EIGHTY ONE MY APOLOGIES. AB
EIGHTY ONE IS THE GENERAL
FEDERAL RELIEF YES OKAY AB
EIGHTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS
SENATOR SKINNER FIVE. SKINNER
HI NIELSEN NIELSEN HI CABALLERO
CABALLERO HI KATIE CORTESE HIGH.
DOLLY DALY HI DORADO. DORADO HI
EGGMAN IN HIGH GROWTH GROVE HI
LAYERED WHERE I'D MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA. MELENDEZ
ABSTAINED MELENDEZ ABSTAINED.
MAN. MAN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE HI PEN
PEN HI RON ROTH FIVE STERN.
STERN AYE BY CAL SKI. AND- DO
WE NEED TO KEEP THAT ROTATION
EVERYTHING TO ONE RIGHT THAT
BILL PASSES THE VOTERS SIXTEEN
TO ONE. RIGHT NOW I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO AB EIGHTY
TO BE. APOLOGIES THE MO YOU YES
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN. AB EIGHTY
TO THE MOTION TO PASS. CENTERS
SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI CABALLERO
CAREER HIGH CORTESE CORTESE HI
DOLLY. DOLLY HI THE RAZA. RADO
HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH
WROTE I LAYERED WHERE I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
SIGN MELINDA'S MAN. MAN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE OTOBO. THE
TROUBLE I'VE BEEN THEN ARE THE
WRONG. ROTH AYE STERN. STERN HI.
SEVENTEEN HI RIGHT THAT BILL-
AB AT TWO YEARS OUT SEVENTEEN
YESES AND SENATOR KABIR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE MOTION ON AB
EIGHTY THREE. BRIGHTENER
COPIERS MOVED TO THIRTY BE
EIGHTY THREE. THE SMALL
BUSINESSES- LICENSING FEE
EXEMPTIONS. AB EIGHTY THREE
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I. CABALLERO HI CORTESE
DAISY HI DOLLY. DAWALY HAIDER
RAZA RUSSELL I EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HI GROW. GROW I LAYERED WHERE
HI MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
MULLIN DESIGN MELINDA'S ODD MAN.
MIN ODDS NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE A
JOE BLOW. CHAUVEAU I PAN THEN I
ROTH ROTH AYE STERN STERN HI.
THE BILL IS. HELLO ONE SECOND.
ALL RIGHT AND- HI WILL REPORT
OUT THE VOTE ON THAT BILL THAT
WAS- A. B. EIGHTY THREE B.
EIGHTY THREE AND THE VOTE WAS A
SEVENTEEN I. ZERO NO VOTE
SEVENTEEN ZERO NO FOR AB EIGHTY
THREE AND SENATOR ALSO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MOVE AB EIGHTY
EIGHT. SENATOR ALSO MOVES AB
EIGHTY EIGHT THIS IS THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS ROLL CALL PLEASE.
AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE MOTION TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOT
VOTING COPYRIGHT CABALLERO HI
CORTESE. CORTESE I DALAI. THE
RAZA THE RUSSELL I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GROW. LEHRER LAYERED
ISLAND WHILE. MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ OBSCENE
MELENDEZ ABSTAINED MAN MAN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI JOE BLOW. THE
TO ABOUT FIVE TEN PAN HI ROTH.
ROTH AYE STERN. STERN ALL RIGHT
WHAT COUNTY. IN THE VOTE ON AB
AN- EIGHTY EIGHT IS FIVE
THIRTEEN NO. ZERO FIVE THIRTEEN
OH ZERO AND- WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE ONE THAT WE DID NOT
CONCLUDE THE VOTE ON. IS THAT
AB AMP THE ONE TO AB EIGHTY
FIVE IN AB AT OKAY LET'S START
BABY EIGHTY. WITH AB EIGHTY
FOUR SORRY EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS FIRST ONE GO HEAD%
EIGHTY FIVE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AB EIGHTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS. GROWTH A JOE BLOW.
STERN KERN HIGH THE COSBY. FOUR
EIGHT FIVE THE BILL THEN IS OUT
WITH THE VOTE OF TWELVE OZ
THREE NO VOTES TWELVE EYES
THREE NO VOTES AT AB EIGHTY
FIVE THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO AB AT THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB
AT MOTION TO PASS STERN.
WIECKOWSKI STERN HI MICHALSKI.
RIGHT AND THE SEND OUT SOS IS.
SEVENTEEN HIS ZERO NO VOTE
RIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
NINE ZERO NO VOTES AND AS I
INDICATED WHEN WE OPENED SB
EIGHTY SEVEN WAS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING SO WILL NOT BE TAKING A
VOTE ON THAT BUT I WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK. ALL OF
YOU THANK OUR STAFF THANK
LEADERSHIP THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE PACKAGE
THAT WE WELL THERE'S STILL ONE
BILL THAT WE WILL HAVE ON OUR
FLOOR WE DID HEAR. THAT THIS
NINE POINT SIX BILLION PACKAGE
PROVIDES FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN SUPPORT OUR
BUSINESSES. TWO POINT SIX
BILLION FOR OUR LOW AND INCOME
FAMILIES IT ALSO PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR CHILDCARE FOR
CALIFORNIA EXPANSION FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS MERCANTE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
RESTORATION OF THE FUNDING CUT
FOR YOU SEE CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND MUCH MORE
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL BE VERY
PROUD I LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING
FOR IT ON THE FLOOR AND AGAIN I
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR. THE
GOVERNOR. HIS STAFF IN OUR
LEADERSHIP AND ALL OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES WHO HEARD
THESE WHO TOOK PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AND THE BUDGET STAFF FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS AND
WITH THAT. I THINK WE CAN
CONCLUDE THIS HEARING MY
CORRECT UP SENATOR DRAWS ARE
GOING OUT AND THEN TEAR THANK
YOU I JUST WANNA ANNOUNCED THAT
ARE BUDGET SUB OMMITTEE FIVE
WILL BE MEETING WE HAVE TO
BREAK FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES AND
THEN IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE THANK YOU. EXCELLENT BAND
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW CONCLUDE.
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING.